[Music]
foreign
so
hey hey it's wednesday it's party stream
i'm now just seeing now that i see it i
check in the back and see if all the
lights are correct it looks like it's
all right
yeah it's okay yeah it's okay at least i
remember to turn it on
and she's [ __ ] with me already what
yes early on the show at least i
remember to turn it on because i forgot
that
no no no i said i remember to turn it on
because i forget i'm in the [ __ ]
office all day but i got to [ __ ] sit
here
but it's it's it's all on we got a bunch
of lights in here i had to have it off
earlier because i was recording one of
my witching hour shows and like i said
that
it makes like a really loud thing it's
all rgbs and [ __ ]
little small rgb's that's beautiful it
makes me feel so that's led once
look i like that it has a bunch of soft
bounce and [ __ ]
i like that i like that it has
snowflakes it makes me feel like it's
christmas time
oh yeah that's actually running a little
too fast i'm gonna slow that down
i did it i did it's two times i usually
slow it down
two times oh now it's like whoa
yeah make that [ __ ] pretty zach is
asking what kind of tablet you got
it's team it's tv
i don't know dude why are you asking
this [ __ ]
i'm too old to give a [ __ ] about that
big one he's like just give me the big
what kind of phone is that man it's a
[ __ ] phone phone
my phone is so [ __ ] old you guys yeah
i don't know if you guys have this
um i don't know if this i don't think
i'm the only person that has this
problem
but apparently so i have headphones so i
can listen to music on my phone like
when i'm out hiking or whatever
and for some reason my phone thinks that
when you plug in
headphones sometimes not always um when
you plug in the headphones
it thinks that it's a microphone maybe
and so that google listen thing will
come on
you know yeah um so sometimes i'll just
be like out on my hike or whatever and
i'll be listening to music and all of a
sudden the music will stop and it'll go
and then it'd be like it's listening and
i'm just like [ __ ] off
did you hear that yeah turn the [ __ ]
music back on i don't need this [ __ ]
zack said he's asking because he's a
tech nerd
dude well that's what i was going to say
because i'm a tech nerd dog
once you get to our age you're just so
indifferent you know we had technology
our whole lives now
51 i give a [ __ ] about what the news
honestly i'm just like
i have preferences like i said i'm a mac
person
i do have like some you know microsoft
[ __ ] like you know
pcs but i really don't like them i like
mac better
but i'm not one of those people that's
all like [ __ ] cultivated or anything
about it
because they're [ __ ] they're all
[ __ ] expensive and all that shit's
gonna go obsolete within a year anyway a
year later your [ __ ] won't be the best
one so it doesn't matter
yeah basically i'm just kind of like
whatever yeah
whatever one is like affordable and it's
like is this like really fast and will
this do what i need to do which frankly
as far as the phone is concerned is not
much that last one i had i kept for like
three or four years it could barely
it's it was barely reliable because the
all the software and the [ __ ] in the sim
card was out of date
so i just went [ __ ] traded it in it
didn't cost much
yeah because you had you have that trade
and things like that i have the trade-in
thing too with my phone but it's been
like years because i'm just so
i hate anything that and i'm not lazy
i'm not
but i hate anything that like
inconveniences me for like five minutes
so if i have to be without a phone and i
have to wait for the new phone to come
and i'm gonna transfer all the [ __ ] over
my new phone i'm just kind of like oh
god it's like pulling teeth i hate it
so sometimes i will have a phone for
like years and years and it's like
really really old and like really
[ __ ]
and it's like so the phone that i have
now is i don't even remember what it is
it's lg
but i think it might be an lg three i
don't know it's like super super old
and it's just like i keep telling myself
it's like god you know because they give
you a deal you know i have cricket
and it's like they give you a deal you
know you get like
you know a new phone for 50 bucks and
blah blah blah
so it's like man i should really do that
but i just haven't got around to it
because it seems like too much of a pain
yeah on today's show we're gonna got a
whole list of our favorite horror movies
jenny's got the list and she goes what
about your list that's what she asked me
about the list and i said my list is the
same as your list
and she goes you're [ __ ] lazy i
didn't say you're [ __ ] lazy i just
said okay lazy
[Laughter]
it really doesn't matter i've probably
seen all the pretty much most of the
movies that she's seen and we have kind
of like similar taste
i guess you could say uh i'm not a huge
horror fan
i kind of like horror comedy more than
anything else so
a lot of mine are going to be on there
and the ones that aren't on there
a lot of people he'll [ __ ] at me yeah
and he'll probably [ __ ] about what
order
it won't matter but okay so here's what
i ended up doing because you guys like
it
this was like really hard somebody
suggested it and i've been wanting to do
a show like that for a really long time
and like i started making a list like a
long time ago and i'm like man this is
[ __ ] impossible
i was trying to make a top 100 and it's
like even then i was just kind of like
[ __ ] this
i just can't i just couldn't winnow it
down any further
so what i ended up doing i said okay i'm
gonna do
like i think cinemassacre did a show
like a while back and they were just
kind of like look we're just gonna pick
our favorite horror movie or movies
from every decade and i was like well
that seems like more
doable so i did that but then i still
ended up like for example
the 70s i went and i went through like
all the movies that came out all the
horror movies came out in the 70s
and i went in there and i was just like
carefully so i was making a list and
then i ended up with like
60 [ __ ] movies so i just i was like
and then i have to winnow it down to
top 20 because i was like this is
ridiculous i'm just you know
and then it was like really really hard
and then i'm just sitting there going oh
man i don't want to take that oh i don't
want to take that one off either and
then like then i had to put him in order
and it was just it was a nightmare
but um so hopefully i mean you know you
guys appreciate it and i think the 80s
was even worse because i think i had 72
movies that i picked out of the 80s and
then i had to
winnow it down to [ __ ] 20. and i was
just like what what i have to take 62
movies off of this list
[ __ ] what am i gonna do
i'm wearing a science fiction i like
more science fiction yeah he's more
accepted
and some of the action type stuff i'm
more into that
i also like stuff that's kind of
historical like some of the historical
movies
we did a thing on uh my peeps [ __ ] uh
the other day which is uh [ __ ] the
free state of jones
and when i'm talking about mississippi
i'm talking about jones county and i i
grew up and
we grew up calling it the free state of
jones
and it's the history of the free state
of jones if you guys didn't see the
review go back and even watch that
yeah we did it it's a good movie it's
about newton knight it's on netflix at
least in the us
and my family on my dad's sides was
in all that [ __ ] new new night they knew
newton night and uh my dad is
knows all the descent the night
descendants and since a lot of them
still there they're all still there a
lot of them are still there
they were there when i was a little kid
and you know they were a lot of them
were there
until i was about 16. a lot of people
left of course because cable tv came out
and
really a lot of people moved on to
greener pastures and um
i guess you could say uh most of the
most of the white kids that i grew up
with from that
area all went to university and they
ended up moving away
afterwards so not all of them but a lot
of them went to universities
and moved away most of them went to like
places like ole miss
but then they left and ended up in
places like tennessee you know up in
nashville and everything in that area
well yeah because you need i mean you
need to
jones county was kind of like mayberry
there was the population density was
very low good-looking people
um it was a mixture of whites and black
and blacks
mississippi is the blackest state in the
united states it's 30 percent black
uh very low income but you got a lot for
your money
yeah low cost of living low cost of
living high status it would have to be
high quality of life people are happy
there um
uh it's uh got a [ __ ] ton of guns per
capita the most guns out of any state
and it has one of the lowest crime rates
out of the state
and um you know don't believe what you
hear on tv people [ __ ] like well it's
probably like
it's lower population density low
population density you see another
person like hey what's up
well i kind of feel like everybody knows
everybody they all grew up yeah
i mean sometimes i think that um and i
you know and i'm not [ __ ] on cities
because i like big cities but um
sometimes if you have to deal with you
know randos every single day and it's
you know crowded
um that stresses you out more than just
like living out in
the middle of nowhere and you don't see
that many people from the other day and
the people you see you do know so it's
not
you're not gonna get that upset about it
you know yeah and uh contrary to what
they'll tell you in hollywood
uh whites and blacks got along well uh
as soon as like the late 80s started to
roll around the 90s the
after that they they got along very well
there um of course you know it has
old people on both sides they they that
didn't
didn't like you know people of the other
race you know but that was the older
generations
and it was like oil and water they
self-segregated
the blacks didn't like the whites the
whites didn't like the blacks because it
was
it was a hundred years basically of
low-intensity race war
uh kind of like something out of south
africa but
that movie explains it the free state of
jones
so you'll you'll see what the deal was
well as i said i think it's interesting
because
the writer director was like you know
there really haven't been all that many
movies about
the reconstruction right and i was like
yeah it's like i can't really
i mean other than like gone with the
wind but that wasn't even really
about that i mean that was kind of about
something else but it's like they don't
really make a lot of movies about that
era
i guess half of the new knight saga was
the civil war the other half was
reconstruction
and it was the civil war just continuing
in
in a low intensity conflict um
and they were the legends that me and
all my other
peers from the mississippi area that we
all grew up with because our dads knew
each other and our grandfathers all knew
each other
it was that kind of place and and uh
turns out one of my best friends who is
we
we consider ourselves to be kin because
for generations our families grew up
side by side his name is david key
and he was a history professor he used
to be a history professor
back in the day at um ole miss
university
and he wrote a book researching what
happened in the free state of jones and
newt knight
and that book inspired the creation of
this movie
um because we'd heard about it but it
wasn't in the history books he had to
research it himself and
find surviving witnesses and records
court records to find out exactly what
happened
because during reconstruction the
unionists
both the unionists and the dixiecrats
wanted to erase that from history they
did not want any more rebellions
against the confederacy or the union
because the free state of jones fought
against both fought against the union
and the confederacy they hit it
it was its own country and
jones was its own country a hundred
years before the [ __ ] civil war it
was a [ __ ] bizarre place
it was like a tribal region yeah exactly
what it was like
kind of like a tribal region of [ __ ]
afghanistan it was
but it was whites and blacks
sharecroppers mostly but it's all there
if you see that movie you guys might
enjoy it
it's historically accurate except for
there was a one little aspect
that they didn't really expound on too
much
later on it showed um during the
the reconstruction phase it showed newt
knight and his rebels most of them black
uh going down to vote and they were
going to vote republican
against the dixiecrats and the
dixiecrats wanted to [ __ ] stop that
and as they marched down there they were
singing songs to john brown
all right a lot of people don't know who
john brown was but he was uh i learned
about him in school yeah but
they didn't really spell it out yeah in
the movie who john brown was
and um anyway john brown was a
there's a white guy who was leading a
slave revolt really
which they were they were trying to say
that newt knight was a guy like john
brown but he was a lot
better man i think than john but john
brown murdered a lot of innocent people
really um newt knight didn't but
um what ended up happening is that the
klan started to attack
southern republicans including black
people that were voting
and the klan worked for the dixiecrats
they were dixie crab dixie kratz were
clan
it was the same [ __ ] there was
interchangeable
in the movie it just shows the clan
attacking blacks and republicans
but they don't show that they make it
look very one-sided
for i guess probably political reasons
you couldn't go out and just kill some
black people and get away with it
the uh the white man's magical
government was not gonna [ __ ]
protect you from that if you went out in
as a clan member and killed some black
people the black people retaliated
they retaliate well who wouldn't yeah
they were that's what i was going to say
like
understandably yeah they try to make
them look like they're effeminate or
something like okay you got us
no no no no it was it was more like
something out of the irish
troubles where it was tit for tat and
tit for tat for a hundred years
yeah they may not they may not attack
you
face to face but you come home and your
house is on fire
and you're like damn have my house
burned down your house burned down cause
yeah i wonder why
they knew they all knew each other so it
was all tit-for-tat and different
just because you put it down white mask
on didn't mean those black people didn't
know who you were they knew you were
they could find out yeah that hood don't
mean nothing so it was
it was basically a damn race war that
went on for about a hundred years
all the way up to the 60s um and
it kind of covers it up until the 40s
yeah although that's kind of like it's
just i mean we talked about it yesterday
uh you know yesterday but it's very
interesting part of history and i'm glad
that my family was in the middle of that
you know
and my family actually fought with new
night that they were
they were that and that was how i became
i inherited southern republicanism and
that [ __ ] kind of
explains why that happened that movie
does
it started in jones county and it was
it was anti-racist
if you were a racist you were a
dixiecrat and clan
back then yeah back then well that went
on all for a long time up until the 60s
yeah yeah um zach is saying uh he
prefers cities because they feel less
lonely
i prefer cities because
it's weird because i prefer cities
because it's just a bunch of random
people because then
there's just a bunch of people and no
one cares what you're doing and no one
is like all up in your business
that's one thing that i never liked
about all this small town oh everybody
knows each other i'm like that sounds
horrifying i don't want people [ __ ]
in the town it's like oh it's my
neighbor it's like dropping by with
cookies and stuff it's like [ __ ] off
[ __ ]
i don't want you know what i mean i just
like leave me alone i don't i don't like
it
so it's like in a lot of ways i like big
cities better because you can be
like anonymous and everyone's like not
up in your grill all the time
you know so that's because i don't like
that i don't like people like all up in
my [ __ ] [ __ ] all the time
i don't like it he's waiting for mango
to show up mango badger
because he was wanting to see this but
he's he's not here yet i have not seen
mango because i haven't seen natila
either
haven't seen bee's nest bees i talked to
bees nests and he was having some
problems in mexico
uh-oh um what happened well he lost uh
he was doing going across the board when
he lost his internet
something like that oh [ __ ] well yeah it
happens
sometimes so um all right paul morses i
don't even know my neighbors names we
don't either um actually the house on
one side of us
we used to know them because they were
cool it was like an extended family
uh they moved out they moved to like a
bigger house somewhere else i think the
house
on one side of us is empty right yeah
there's nobody in that one yeah i don't
think anybody's like somebody came in we
thought somebody was moving in but i
guess it all fell through because they
didn't
um but on the other side yeah i don't
know like i know them to be like hey
bro what's up or but i don't know their
names or nothing and that's kind of the
way i like it to be honest with you
i'll like you know what i mean it's like
i you know i do my hikes in the morning
and i see the same people
like every day because everybody walks
along that trail like you know they're
walking their dogs they're riding bikes
or whatever
and it's like i know them by sight and
i'm just like hey you
um but that's it like i don't you know i
don't want to like stop and [ __ ] talk
to people because
man like i said leave me a [ __ ] world
it's hat time
do you guys drink with any of your
neighbors no no
well like like i said the neighbors we
used to have
it was an extended family right it was
husband and wife it was a bunch of kids
a bunch of their cousins and a bunch of
their kids it was like an extended
family it's a big house
big house it's bigger than ours and it
was like two stories we had a [ __ ] ton
of motorcycles they were getting new
motorcycles every six months
yeah they were really really into like
motorcycles or something like that so
i'm going to test all their bikes
so he would go over there and like talk
to them and [ __ ] um they were cool and
like sometimes like on fourth of july
they'd buy what they bought like three
thousand dollars for the fireworks or
something one year
yeah yeah yeah so we saw the fireworks
like the kids they were out there like
professional fireworks we were blowing
the [ __ ] place up
that was like two or three years ago
some of our neighbors are they're not
from this
country they're they're they're
foreigners and i think they were [ __ ]
scared
as loud as that [ __ ] was they were just
like their lights turned off their oh
they didn't even come out and look
i didn't know yeah well i mean yeah they
bought like the good [ __ ]
about the good [ __ ] and they're like
we're just gonna go out in our back
patio
yeah and do all these after we did that
[ __ ] firework shoot we had to get out
the big old push brooms and [ __ ]
broom
man the whole [ __ ] plate because
there's all these little damn
[ __ ] everywhere cardboard cartridges and
rockets that fly out of those big old
[ __ ]
i was still finding like a little
cardboard [ __ ] like a few days after
throwing little bomblets everywhere
yeah and it was uh it had cats were
scared to death
yeah they were all they hid under the
bed like all night it was probably like
200 pounds of fireworks
yeah they had a lot of [ __ ] yeah they
were into well they had a connection
yeah so a lot of that stuff they didn't
pay for oh
they had a connection
ah zach says i'm gearing up to move out
of my parents place and i have no idea
where how to start you guys got any good
advice
oh my god it's always like well it's
always kind of like a hard
transition i moved out at 18.
i moved down so long ago well it's weird
because i kind of moved when i was
okay like i was 18 19 and then i went to
college
and then i got married when i was 22
and then we moved to the uk and but
we went kind of back and forth to the uk
and like when we were in the us we kind
of
we lived at my grandparent my
grandmother's house because my granddad
was dead by that time
so we lived in my grandmother's house
for a little while but then like we went
like we bought let's see we got an
apartment then we moved to tampa
and got an apartment went to clearwater
got an apartment then we came back to
daytona bought a house
which man i don't know if i'd ever do
that again like i had that house for a
long time and i liked that house but
it's a lot harder to move out on your
own it is
well it is when i was a kid it's
expensive when i was a kid
at 18 um i was working
as a waiter at a [ __ ] bob's big boys
i think they call it yeah it's a bob's
big boys i think they call it elias
brothers was up in michigan at that time
and just as a waiter i could afford a
one-bedroom apartment that was nice
and a car and i could go out uh once
nowadays bud because i was in those days
i was pulling down
in that old economy back in the late 80s
i was pulling down about a hundred and
fifty dollars a night
oh my gosh that's pretty good i would
love to make that much money yeah even
nowadays that's a lot of money yeah
i was so scared about paying my rent one
time i lost track
of of paying rent and and
didn't realize that i had already paid
it and real quick paid it again
so i was ahead i was [ __ ] running
kind of hungry at that time i was like
god damn man i thought i'd forgotten to
pay it
yeah because i was kid i didn't write it
down
you know living on my own and [ __ ]
i mean the thing about it like like i
said for a long time
um you know i owned a house in daytona
with my
ex-husband you know and um
it wasn't an expensive house it was uh i
think it
how much did we pay for that 85 000
maybe which is like not much
and then but by the time that we got
divorced
um the real estate market had [ __ ] the
bed
so much that it was worse that it was
worth
less than half of that so i was just
kind of like we were getting divorced
anyway and i said you know what [ __ ]
this i'm just like not even i'm not
gonna try to sell it i'm just gonna
[ __ ]
leave it yeah um you know my ex-husband
lived there for a little while like on
his own
i moved over orlando i got my own
apartment now the apartment i lived in
this was back in 2010
i think back in 2010 i got an apartment
in
winter park i think it was off of loma
and it was 650
a month that was just the rent it didn't
include anything
and um it was a one bedroom apartment
and it was
roach infested yeah you went there
you know i got her out of there though
it was a nice place it's just that
it wasn't terrible it wasn't the best
neighborhood but it wasn't like a
terrible neighborhood
it wasn't her apartment that was
infested with roaches it was
the upstairs one and they were getting
into her apartment
through the holes in the walls where the
water heater was i had to bug bomb that
place many
anyway coming in and they were coming in
through the damn electrical sockets
coming out through the actual socks
they were in the walls there was no i
had to put everything
in the refrigerator in the refrigerator
when i left it because
at that time i was working in daytona
still and i worked the night shift
so what i would do is that i would drive
over to daytona i would do my night
shift and then i had a friend
whose parents let me stay at their house
so i didn't have to drive all the way
back to orlando so i would stay there
like some nights
and then because i only worked like
three or four days a week and so then i
would come back
to orlando so while i wasn't in the
apartment because i wasn't in the
apartment for like two or three days at
a time and sometimes i'd stay at his
place too
um which was in altamonte springs um
so if i was going to be away i would
take everything like seriously i would
take everything the coffee pot
everything i would wrap everything in
plastic bags and put everything in the
refrigerator
so the roaches wouldn't climb on it yeah
because the roaches were getting in the
coffee pot they were getting
the toaster they were just everything
they were those little german
cockroaches little bitty german
cockroaches once they're in
i mean [ __ ] especially once they're in a
apartment complex
that's it that apartment complex yeah
they just
run rampant you can't you can't get rid
of them they just run rampant
and we and we had it happen in this
house too i don't know where it came
from but god damn though
yeah it's like we for a little while
they they uh got in
they got in and made a damn hive
underneath the sink no no it was it was
on top
of the um i thought it was under the
fridge no no or
in the fridge no no no behind the frame
no
it was behind the um it was up above the
wat
the dishwasher remember oh that's right
i had to pull the dishwasher out and
they were living up on
living up in the counter on the top yes
because they were going down inside the
dishwasher
to eat food off the dirty dishes before
you turned it on see they're not so dumb
yeah so bub but the thing is is that
there's a separation between this house
and the others so if you bug bomb the
house
you kill them but yeah this isn't
attached to any it's not attached to it
it's a regular house but if you're in an
apartment complex and the infestation is
in another apartment
there's like why just go down to this
other one yeah they're going under
another one and they'll come in through
the walls and go into another
one my apartment was clean i wasn't
there like most of the time like
like half the time i was not even at the
apartment
at my house yeah was it your house or i
was you know staying with my friend's
parents in daytona or i was working
so it's or i was at the gym or whatever
so i was like i was barely at this
this apartment went to our bathroom
bathroom one time
and uh looked down on the soap dish and
had a damn little german cockroach on
top of the piece of stuff look at him
eating no he was eating that soap yeah
they'll eat soup
they eat like the um the glue off of
books they'll eat
because she had all the food wrapped up
inside the refrigerator there was
nothing for them to eat
outside you know there's nothing there's
like one meat eating the soap
it's ridiculous i mean you have to like
give them props for being really really
adaptable
okay yes they'll eat soap i said i gotta
get you out of here
so we moved in together
yeah that's how that happened but yeah
so this house here
it is kind of expensive florida is not
too bad but it still like
is pretty expensive um to get a a nice
apartment that's not like in the middle
of [ __ ]
the ghetto yep graham's right he says
the only way to get rid of them in that
situation is to put a
put a tent over the whole building
you've got a bug yeah and the
and these and these these apartments
here won't do that
they won't do it too much money you have
to kick everybody out for [ __ ]
several days and [ __ ] and they just want
to do it but i will
say suck it up it's florida now if it
was because all our all the high-end
[ __ ] that's being built now
it's separated there's no one big
apartment complex
unless there's something downtown and
that's still old they don't make those
anymore well no because some of the
stuff they built around here like grand
oaks that's town houses
um so there's rows of them there's like
a row and it's like four or five of them
like in a row
you know what i mean they do do that um
well they fumigate that though
yeah yeah but i mean i will say though
that i had
i bug bombed my apartment three times
yeah i think and that did the trick you
realize they got 47 people on here and
we're talking about roaches
it's a sidetrack show you can talk about
we can talk about whatever we want
but i'm just saying that um so that
apartment was 6.50
like i said it wasn't the best
neighborhood
but i walked around the neighborhood i
went like because it was a convenience
store i went up to buy cigarettes
because i smoked at the time and i went
up to buy stuff and i would and i've
never felt like i was going to get
murdered
although i will note that a girl did get
kidnapped
from that uh very same convenience store
that i lived right by because the
convenience store was like
right here and the apartment complex was
like right next to it and i just like
lived right there
um but it was like before i lived there
and um
so i didn't think i was gonna get shot
or anything but i did
i didn't like it that i was on the
ground floor so i did kind of feel like
you know
maybe could come through the window or
come through the um because i had like a
screened in back porch and i kind of
felt like well somebody will come in
there and like break open my [ __ ]
sliding glass doors or whatever
um but it wasn't a terrible neighborhood
but it wasn't a great neighborhood let's
put it like that
this house um is the rent
is 1800. but
this is a four bedroom three bath
yeah house i don't know what the square
footage is i don't remember
um and the 1800s we have two garages and
it has two garages
a big two car garage and a one car
garage one of them i converted it into a
damn gym it's air-conditioned and
everything
painted that you got lasers and [ __ ]
lights and [ __ ] stereo
there's another fridge in there yeah
fridge back there
it looks nice the big garage looks nice
because we don't know like we have a big
driveway
i don't need to like park well yeah the
landlord owns the place so he didn't
[ __ ] with me well the thing about the
landlords that we have
are they own what 12 no
houses or more than that more i think
they own like they own a bunch of
30 of them or something they own a bunch
of houses and they rent them out
and so if they can find a tenant that
will live there and will actually like
take care of the places like we painted
the whole [ __ ]
we like you know do things too even
though it's like a rental it's not our
house
really but um so they're very willing to
like give us a break
um you know so and the 1800 i was gonna
say that actually covers
lawn service so the lawn guys come
once a week and trim the trees and cut
the grass and show like that so we don't
have to do any of that
yeah um which is nice now nothing else
nothing else is included we still have
to pay like electric and all that [ __ ]
which is kind of expensive that's all
standard [ __ ] for florida though in this
area that's all the standard [ __ ]
yeah zach says need a roommate you're
the wrong sex zach
[Laughter]
what you have to have a girl roommate
girl why does it gotta be a girl
i don't know you don't want another dude
living in here come on mess up
we may need a roommate one of these days
maybe okay oh he wants to talk about
he's very excited about this
yesterday did we say this on the on the
movie show probably
but yesterday on the way to the post
office he went to
he went to the [ __ ] the man clinic as
i call him right
what is it called even it's called a
mint it's called uh i don't [ __ ] know
it it started with an n no no it's
called that's
it that's there's two different ones in
there this is called something like
rebuild
sandra said jenny did they find the
kidnapped girl i don't think they ever
found her actually
she's missing still check that [ __ ] out
i'm sure she got murdered
there you go i have to give him the
injections you guys
yeah he got the one he got the first
injection at the office
yeah but then they were like well no you
have to do it once a week
so well no they she's she's like
the the girl at the at the clinic was
like okay well you just she's like you
don't have to be like super
specific she's like just do it in the
arm or like she said right above the
butt
like in the muscle right above your
glutes so i'm so i'm gonna have to do
that
well i could have done it there but i
have to go there every week they said uh
if
we can ship it to you for ten dollars a
month and you don't have to be here at
all
or you can come here and pick it up it's
only two miles away i'll pick it i mean
it's like right there
right here so i'll just go pick it up
once a month and then if it was downtown
that would be different
i'll shoot it myself yeah you know if
you shoot it
and when you press the plunger you kind
of go slow because it's a little thin
needle and it's real thick like like
honey
yeah so it takes a while to come to
press the damn plunger all the way down
it's only one milliliter so there's not
a whole lot it goes in
200 milligrams per week that's a pretty
decent dose
if you were to give that to a dude with
[ __ ] if you were to give that to a 20
year old
guy that would explode it'd be like
doing roids
i know they weren't my blood work came
back man my total testosterone was only
[ __ ] like 145
it was like the testosterone of a dead
man testosterone
you might as well be a gross ass girl
like a 70 no
i'm just amazing i don't know i don't
know what you're talking about
it's like the testosterone of a [ __ ]
70 year old the scent of a sick
seventy year old look i can't believe
that i build any
i built any muscle at all working out
but it explains a lot like why you're so
like bummed out all negative and [ __ ]
and [ __ ] sleepy and tired no drive
and that's why right there my test was
supposed to i think it was 145
i think is what it was or was it 165. i
can look at it but i think
i thought it was 160 or 165. i
if you have under if you have 240 and
under you're clinically [ __ ] low it's
supposed to be
for say a guy in his 20s or 30s is real
good health
somewhere between 700 and 1100.
so that there's gonna bump me up to like
a thousand probably we'll see how it
goes based on what my flight
and then they gave me some pituitary
gland stuff so uh to encourage to
produce your own testosterone
like a whole box and then i got a
[ __ ] bunch of estrogen blockers they
gave me it's a fun
it's a [ __ ] drug box that's to keep
to get you from the gyno like the rock
got he doesn't want moves
yeah i'm on a good [ __ ] program then
and then [ __ ] just you saw a little
what's her name oh [ __ ] what's that
girl's name
jessie oh is that her okay with the
little one yeah
yeah little jessie she's super cute when
you go to these clinics all right it's
not [ __ ] like
this [ __ ] so [ __ ] funny you're not
going to a doctor's office especially
not in florida
you go to these [ __ ] clinics these
dudes for getting upgrades
okay you're getting upgraded well yeah
this is like you know not sick people
yeah so so like i said if you're going
to work in the medical field it's
probably a lot less depressing
you go there it's like crossfit doctor's
office in a strip club
all the [ __ ] girls that work there
are [ __ ] cute and they're all wearing
these little
little [ __ ] tight shiny black workout
pants just be just tight with a little
[ __ ]
it's like a fake it's like a it's like a
medical smock
over that but just the way it is it just
it looks like a stripper interpretation
or a porn interpretation of a nurse
and anyway a little bit yeah yeah you
didn't notice them pants i guess
yeah i did you notice that pants yeah
yeah so
uh i mean just enough to come in and
[ __ ] [ __ ] once they start hooking you
up you know they work for the doctor
but it's obviously this is like a
florida thing this is legal drug dealing
all right sure these are all
performance-enhancing drugs
women women were in there too though
when they're getting these [ __ ]
hormone [ __ ] yeah because they do
like a weight loss
weight loss as well yeah they're giving
them [ __ ] like trend
trembling [ __ ] [ __ ] burn every bit
of fat off of them
trampoline and [ __ ] mood stabilizers
and stuff
so you don't go [ __ ] crazy because
train will [ __ ] make you a maniac
without losing although as i mentioned
yesterday you'd at least be a skinny
minion
yeah be a skinny ass maniac well the
mood stabilizers would keep all that
[ __ ]
that's worth it but it's kind of like
going to a [ __ ] cosmetic surgery
[ __ ] place or something nobody's sick
so the whole [ __ ] environment is very
[ __ ] well everybody comes there
because
you know they want enhancement
absolutely yeah you know it's it's all
like kind of reminded me of well it's
all voluntary it's not like oh i feel
like [ __ ] i have to come here
yeah no it's not and then it's kind of
like kind of reminded me of the movie i
realized i was like man this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] florida as [ __ ] the first time i
went there
it kind of felt like that movie painting
game
yeah you know you know like the the uh
uh the gym at paint and game yeah it's
just kind of like that kind of
environment you know like
they know what they're doing but they're
not taking it real seriously because
nobody's dying
nobody's it's not like you're working in
hospice yeah or anything with like
they sold me that trt compound and they
go now is there anything else you might
want
and i was like we do have an anti-aging
protocol this
anti-aging protocol and this and that
and hair regrowth and this and i said
let me see they had a menu
it was like another couple hundred
dollars and i'm seeing what's what
what's there like
yeah and i was like that's [ __ ] hgh
freaking human growth hgh and topical
[ __ ] steroid treatment for [ __ ]
hair follicles i'll take one of each
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah give me some of
that [ __ ] i was i felt [ __ ] important
you know
i said well let me go ahead and i'll do
this trt i'll do this trt regiment we'll
see how i feel they go
yeah yeah yeah you do that dude yeah
yeah yeah yeah so they're they're well
thing is they're pretty they're trying
to upsell they're trying to upsell
they're also trying to you know and the
best way to upsell you is to [ __ ]
kind of appeal to your [ __ ] vanity
and [ __ ] well yeah you
you should know that you were i was a
salesman i know exactly what they're
doing you know what they're doing but
it's still effective it's the easiest
people to sell to this other salesman
you unders
because you understand what the what the
technique is you're like i see you're
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're good yeah it's [ __ ] funny
it is very funny yeah well my favorite
thing is
about legal drug deal because i never
because he went there by himself like
the first time but like i ended up
you know going there because he was just
going to get the injection
and we were going to like the post
office and the post office is like right
you know like less than a mile away from
there so i was like oh we have to go to
the post office anyway so whatever
you got to go get your injection so i
was sitting in there and i was like my
favorite thing
is that they have i we used to have one
of these in
uh my health class in high school where
they have that thing it's like this is
what five
pounds of body fat looks like and they
have that like it's it's like an
artistic sculpture of like this kind of
honeycomb
colored thing that's like kind of all
thing and it's like this is human fat
yeah this is what it looks like in your
ass like right now
yeah right florida florida's [ __ ]
amazing man florida's amazing
it's [ __ ] cool i like it kind of
reminds me of california
back in the good old days back in the
70s and the 80s
depends on where you go though where in
florida yeah where in florida and
wearing cats because a lot of
well a lot of florida is still pretty
rednecky and it's like i'm not really
into that
we're in the i4 corridor though it's
different i mean we're in orlando or
like outside right outside of orlando so
orlando is actually
pretty cool yeah yeah zach just looking
at you bro you got low tea i could tell
don't hate on zach like that
effeminate features you got man [ __ ]
no brow ridges
yeah what he needs to have like
neanderthal breath yeah
[ __ ] right i'm gonna [ __ ] we gotta
get you [ __ ] t
boosted and when when they're done t
boosting that [ __ ] ass we're gonna
move you up to like 1100 [ __ ]
your testosterone will be like 1100 and
then your beard growth will be [ __ ]
amazing
and uh then you'll you'll look like a
member of zz time you'll end up
you'll end up being a [ __ ] leather
daddy when they're done with you you'll
be
i'll have you hanging out with toby my
leather daddy friend
there'd be also all kinds of wild [ __ ]
going on between you two man listening
to the judas priest wearing leather and
[ __ ]
you'd be going down to the manhole or or
the ramrod
one of these clubs like that beating
[ __ ] out of each other
gay bars having this [ __ ] name
masochistic sado masochistic [ __ ]
warrior male homosexuality dominating
each other
power trading zach says i'm already
pretty hairy already
your power you you that's cause you're
young though it'll t boost your ass out
to like [ __ ] 1200 on your [ __ ]
on your test your [ __ ] free test will
be [ __ ] like
through the moon [ __ ] cialis and all
that [ __ ] hard on pills you just
[ __ ] hit that [ __ ] right there but
those work really good
yeah they look they weren't good but i
[ __ ] found out just from personal
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
you know i [ __ ] i listen to a lot a
lot of veterans and stuff you know
um [ __ ] we're getting all really off the
subject even though there's no [ __ ]
there's no subject what are you worried
about all right there's a um
uh like a 31 a dude comes out he's a
marine raider he comes out at [ __ ] 31
years old he had like a [ __ ] 12 years
of service
and he [ __ ] felt all depressed
because when you're in these military
units especially the hard ones like
[ __ ] you know
airborne infantry airborne recon type
[ __ ] [ __ ] sf
ranger army rangers marine raiders
you're living way up here way way way up
here on an emotional level you know what
i mean you have all this [ __ ] drive
and [ __ ]
because there's an external threat and
when you leave
service all that [ __ ] goes away and you
[ __ ] you just hormones just damn
crash
you become real depressive so after he
got out he [ __ ] just didn't feel good
they did some blood work on him
and his testosterone was lower than mine
i think his was 125.
and he was a 31 year old dude so they t
boosted the [ __ ] out of him and he said
after a couple weeks he was
[ __ ] back on top he's [ __ ] doing
great
it's just and you know he was talking
about his whole journey through it it's
just something like
uh you know women go through [ __ ]
menstrual cycles and [ __ ] like that
it's a lot of guys aren't realizing it
but it's happening to men
too hormones have to be balanced a guy
can get so depressed
that his [ __ ] testosterone will shut
down
and you can't get him undepressed
without [ __ ]
getting his hormone levels back up and
then he'll work his way out of that
depression
now the problem is is that giving those
[ __ ] hormones to him
kind of shuts down natural production
there's a bunch of biological stuff
happens
he can't come off of that usually you go
on trt it's for life
and it's just because there's only so
much gas in your tank
and if you're [ __ ] living a real high
energy emotional energy life
early you kind of empty that tank out
because
humans didn't evolve to live for very
long that's really what it was
especially dudes
especially dudes if you were [ __ ]
running [ __ ] at 300 percent normal
up until you were famous there's not
much left to you after 30. so you're
gonna need what's called exogenous
[ __ ]
hormones or outside support to [ __ ]
bring you back into that state that you
were in
and you can live a long time uh and live
[ __ ] strong forever until you die
with if you have exogenous hormonal
support
just look at jack o'lane he died at like
80 something i thought he was 90s
90 maybe 90 early 90s and he looked
great
right up into his 90s he was a [ __ ]
great athlete jack lalanne you guys can
look him up
should i say my maternal grandmother is
still alive and she's in her 90s yeah
i think [ __ ] jack [ __ ] swam the
english channel with
towing a boat with a rope in his teeth
and he did that i think 45. now he i
don't think he was totally natural i
think he was natural up until he was
about 50
and it looked like he was just from
there on out because this was a long
time ago back in the 60s i think he was
doing a very low
dosages of anavar which is an anabolic
steroid
didn't look like he was spiking it or
cycling it looked like he was just using
it
that's about what trt would do for you
you know i don't know what his sexual
function was like though
because there's all kinds of estrogen i
hope you don't know that that would be
weird if you knew that he didn't say
he said back in those days they were
real
shy about giving details about what they
were taking and what it was doing to him
he looked great he looked strong but we
don't know he didn't leave me right
there
that i like about nowadays is everyone's
just like you don't have to hide it
anymore well and everything's just like
honestly i would rather people err on
the side of too much information than
too little information
i mean sometimes if people tell you some
stuff you're like bro come on it's like
i don't know you got to share
information
share information because i feel like
that makes other people feel better
because they feel like they're not
alone like i'm not the only person going
through this or whatever somebody asked
earlier um
is it true that gots don't wear sneakers
i have
if they're cute sneakers and you're i
have sneakers for walking like in hiking
but they are uh completely black yeah
so no so i don't know if that answers
your question
[Laughter]
no goth girls could wear sneakers but
they have to be cute
and they have to be with the right
outfit
i just have kind of like it looks
fetishy and looks like it came out of a
porn scene then yeah they'd wear it
yeah yeah and honestly i've hiked a few
times in
black motorcycle boots also so
but i do have like a pair of they're
sort of like sneakers i guess but i
don't
i'm not a big fan of those big puffy
sneakers and i
will not wear white sneakers that's for
sure they have to be
all over black i don't like white ones i
don't know like colored ones i don't
want any [ __ ] white stripes on there
i want nothing on there like that
they just got to be black and they have
to be small i don't like puffy ones
um that says what tom's describing ain't
very manly but we don't know what he's
talking about because that was a long
time ago yeah i'm not sure about that
you must be talking oh the manhole
cesco's a gay bar called the manhole i
love it yeah that was [ __ ]
boston back in the day
had [ __ ] is this [ __ ] oh man i
want to tell
okay i was coming back from fenway and i
was i
i was coming back from fenway i was went
to [ __ ] place called uh
it was called venus de milo and i was
walking from venus to milo and i was
trying to get back on
on the damn t line to get back to i
think kenmore
square so i could go to man ray and i
had to pass
this club and it was called the ram rod
i love that name for the record that's a
great thing and a ramrod was a [ __ ]
gay leather
bar and that's exactly as soon as you
hear that name you know exactly what
that is
yeah that is like that's exquisite
branding yeah and i was about like
i was like 25 i guess 26
it was maybe about i don't know 95 96
around that time i just got out of the
army
and [ __ ] i was gothed out like a
[ __ ]
i looked like something out of interview
with a vampire the [ __ ] 1800s [ __ ]
smart coat
[ __ ]
[ __ ] gloves i [ __ ] had [ __ ] um
like a a [ __ ] light blue foundation
with [ __ ] white
powder and [ __ ] look like 17 or 1800s
makeup going and [ __ ]
looked like something right out of
[ __ ] interview with the vampire
and i didn't know about the ram rod i
walked right in front of it not in front
of a whole bunch of [ __ ] harley
davidson motorcycles a bunch of gay
dudes all [ __ ] in there [ __ ] biker
outfits
and they're going whoa they start cat
calling the [ __ ] out of me and they go
look at the ass on that boy
somebody else goes [ __ ] nice yeah he
says look at the ass on that boy
it's like smalling
and i i had to play it off you know what
i mean i didn't want to encourage it but
i had to play it off because what are
you going to show fear
so i just started the swagger a little
bit more like that well that was
probably
exactly the right reaction yeah and they
didn't follow me though
well yeah because only they're just
showing appreciation okay so that was
the ram rod
a few years later a few years later
competition for it opened up a few
blocks down and it was called the
manhole
see i love that the manhole and the bra
and the ram right
so good yeah that was fun i can't
remember like there was a gay bar in
daytona but i can't remember what it was
called
it had a sign that was like like a
rocket and it was like a neon rocket but
i can't remember what the name of the
zodiac
i don't know it was something that
didn't have anything to do with like the
[ __ ] rocket
yeah but i don't regret ken just goes
exactly tom i don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about yeah
[ __ ] bro we forgot what we said
[Laughter]
joe nash says remember the old 80s movie
vice squad the pimp's name was ramrod
yeah what's it really yeah see i think
that
is i think that is the best
gay bar name i mean well except
in orlando we had like a couple like
everybody knows about pulse
unfortunately i'm not gonna talk about
that but um
kind of the one that we used to go to
for the fetish thing that they did
is just called southern knights which to
me sounds like
a j it just sounds very like a generic
that sounds like some [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's a generic name you're gonna be
[ __ ] listening to jimmy buffett
wasting away again in margaritaville
yeah it kind of gives me that vibe or
like it's kind of like a jock bar
because there's kind of like a lot of
those
but it's not it's like and i really
really wish they had named it something
else
because it's like every time like the
night that we went to was called escape
which was a good name
oh that was fetish but the manhole and
ramrod was not florida that was [ __ ]
boston
yeah boston that was outside fenway
fenway park was where near where the
[ __ ] main clubs were
no you could do whatever you wanted in
boston boston was
boston was [ __ ] and that was back in
the 90s but you know there was a lot of
cities that were like that you know
san francisco [ __ ] you know it's
[ __ ] filled with [ __ ] places like
that
um i didn't live there but you know i
heard about them
there was stuff in new york that was
like that so
it was just [ __ ] kind of common [ __ ]
ever from what i understand [ __ ] um
austin and dallas new york are like that
now a lot [ __ ] ton of gay bars and
[ __ ]
well austin's kind of always been yeah
that's kind of like that yeah and
evidently it has always been like that
like going back to the 70s yeah yeah
so it's not austin was kind of like you
know it's kind of like it
it long has had a reputation of being
like the only city in texas that was
kind of like friendly to
weirdos florida never gave a [ __ ] i
don't think
like i said it depends where you go like
i said i was talking about i was born
here orlando
and miami and tampa and tampa they never
gave a [ __ ]
i mean like i said it depends where you
go because a lot of florida i'm not
gonna lie
is still pretty rednecky well yeah we're
talking about that's the panhandle yeah
you go for
the panhandle is the same as mississippi
and alabama and louisiana it's exactly
the same
pretty much actually it might be worse
panhandle might be worse
because if i understand some of those
cities some of those towns scared
cities but some of those towns in the
panhandle from what i understand
are nothing but just huge trailer parks
yeah of rednecks and other ones are just
kind of hidden out in the swamps kind of
like over there
near where we [ __ ] went to go see
your mom
they're just houses out in the middle of
the woods and that's like ocala wood
floor
yeah that's central central florida yeah
um
we're in central florida too but there's
a weird it's called the i4 corridor if
you're not from here yeah
and it goes from daytona to tampa it
goes all the way across the state east
to west
and along there there's like a lot of
cool cities
but outside of that other than
gainesville which is actually pretty
cool because university of florida is
there so there's like a lot of college
[ __ ] there um but outside of that
um is pretty rural
it's like a lot of farms it's a lot of
rednecky [ __ ] it's a lot even daytona
where i grew up i was born there
um it's better now than it used to be
because it's kind of expanding a bit
but when i was growing up it was like
super super rednecky because we had like
[ __ ]
all we had there we had the [ __ ] the
nascar
you know daytona international speedway
that was like the big draw
and then you had pretty much the only
club they had there for a long time was
called the rockin ranch
which should tell you something yeah let
me go get you another drink right here
okay um you know later
a couple of us like when i was in my
teens
um some people opened like some cool
[ __ ] there was a
there was a little bitty like coffee
house
uh you know live venue at first it was
called up and adam and then they called
it something else
and then there was a they had a little
punk club for a little bit
but it was never a real and there's like
some cool [ __ ] there there was like a
really cool like secondhand bookstore
there's a really cool secondhand music
store
but it you know that it was really
really hard to find anything there for
you know people like me i guess
so it's like so something that i really
really i don't know
it's better than it used to be i guess
but
man back in the day it was like really
really hard growing up there because it
felt like everyone
was a redneck except me and even when i
was in high school
you know i hung out with like the only
goth and punk people in town
and there was like maybe 10 of us maybe
and um you know there wasn't really
anywhere to go would you hand me that
empty glass right there
that was my water glass do you want
water no okay
but there i mean there wasn't really
anywhere to go you could go to the
movies
um when i got older you could go to
um up in atom or whatever they called it
later
um and that was pretty much it
um you know it's like the movie theater
did rocky horror picture show
sometimes like on saturdays in the 90s
you could go to that
and that was about it um you know
so where i grew up it was like really
you had to drive all the way to orlando
to see any like decent shows
and um for a long time i didn't have a
car
my brother had a car so when i got a
little bit older we could drive over and
see
you know if peter murphy was playing or
something like that in orlando
um but i don't know it was just like
that's kind of maybe that's why i kind
of like romanticized bigger cities and
stuff like that just because i grew up
in a place that was just so
i don't know like antithetical to like
everything that i liked
and it was really hard to like [ __ ] it
like sometimes like even nowadays like a
lot of um bands that would tour like
bands that i liked that would tour
a lot of them won't even bother like
coming to florida
they'll just like oh we'll play atlanta
and then we're gonna [ __ ] off to the
other part of the country because if
you're coming down to florida
florida is very large and it's very long
and if you want to play in orlando or
miami or whatever
you know it takes a long time to get way
the [ __ ] back up to
the rest of the country because the you
know florida's so long so
a lot of bands particularly if they're
you know more
uh you know alternative or whatever a
lot of them won't bother
it's like so as far south as they'll
come as atlanta and then they'll just
[ __ ] off somewhere else
so we had a lot of [ __ ] that happened
where like a lot of tours of bands that
i wanted to see
would not come here just because it
wasn't worth it
to them you know what i mean because
they found oh it's [ __ ] florida we
don't like you know
it it takes too long to get to orlando
back up then they go to miami and then
they gotta go it just takes too long and
like they just didn't bother and i can't
blame them for not bothering but it's
just kind of like
because they were like oh we'll go to
atlanta because that's a giant city
but you know why bother going down there
orlando miami tampa
that would be the only cities they would
bother with and sometimes they wouldn't
even bother with that just because it
was so much travel time
and i get why they wouldn't do it like i
said because it's saving money
but it was a bummer for me i mean and
like i said this was kind of like this
is why i'm bummed out i never got to see
i mean nick cave he's my favorite i
never got to see him the only
[ __ ] time that he was ever going to
play in florida
he played on the lollapalooza tour in
94 or 95 whenever the [ __ ] it was
whenever like let lovin can't see him
[Music]
huh oh i'm going to say be back have to
run out of error oh okay
we'll still be here probably when you
get back but um yeah
you misspelled two it's
his two
[Laughter]
man i thought that was my lookout like
the grammar nazi thing that's what i do
but um but yeah so i had never seen him
and i was super excited because he was
going to play lollapalooza in 94 or 95.
and they were going to play in [ __ ]
deland of all places which if you don't
know is the city
in between daytona beach and orlando
daytona beach is on the coast
orlando is kind of in the middle what's
up so it's like this little so they had
a fair ground there they were going to
play and i was like super excited
i was going to see like l7 and all this
other kind of [ __ ] too she wants to go
outside
okay so i had tickets for it and then
the morning of the show come here the
night before the show
we had it was summer
um so the night before the show we had
these horrible horrible thunderstorms
like we have here in florida because
it's the [ __ ] tropics
okay well that's good sometimes she does
that did she tell me that she wants to
go out the front don't leave that door
open like that okay
i don't like the door open it's like it
weird yeah okay she's gonna go out
okay so i had bought tickets i was super
excited but then there was like a really
bad thunderstorm like the night before
and like the morning i woke up and i was
just like all jacked and i was like
we're going to lollapalooza i'm going to
see nick cave it's like i'm going to see
l7 i don't remember who the [ __ ]
headliner was i didn't care about that
and um then they said oh well we had to
cancel it because the storms overnight
caused the stage to sink into the mud
and so they so we can't do it now and
i was so [ __ ] bummed and that was
like probably the only chance i ever had
and then this
ironic thing was that my sister lives in
atlanta
and uh still and so
for this year she bought me tickets to
see nick cave
in atlanta for my birthday because he
was playing there like early october of
2020
and obviously you guys know how that
[ __ ] went everything got cancelled
in 2020 so obviously i didn't get to see
him there either
now so it's kind of like am i ever going
to get to see nick cave my sister's got
to see him like two times
she saw him in denver where she used to
live and i think she saw him somewhere
else too i don't remember where
but uh she's got to see him two times
and i'm not going to see him at all
i'm kind of pissed off about it it
actually might be time to go ahead and
do the list
you want to do the list let's do the
list because it looks like we uh
looks like we got everybody we're going
to get right now so sheila ann says
redneck riviera that's exactly what it
is
daytona beach i've seen daytona beach
called that [ __ ] mango just showed up
where you been badger hey man there you
are man wait no we were wondering where
you were
yeah now we just wait for tila to show
up
she might be busy i don't know yeah seth
says i was lucky
lucky enough to see nick cave about
four-ish years ago
he was of course incredible see how it's
like i'm so jealous
i've never got to see him he's i think
he's the only
okay i never got to see the fall and
obviously now i can't because marky
smith
is dead but um i never got to see
uh nick cave and i'm really really
pissed off about it he just never played
here he never played in florida
so that lollapalooza was the first time
he had ever played in florida and i was
super jacked and then it got [ __ ]
canceled because of the [ __ ]
thunderstorms
i was so mad [ __ ] florida and it's
[ __ ] weather i swear
um all right somebody said something dj
maniac says i had the same problem with
body count
i actually saw a body count in
jacksonville
i think early 90s
yeah me and my friend went they were
really good
[Laughter]
badgers said he was late today he had
some things to sort out
well yes badger all the way from the uk
don't we all yeah
yeah we haven't we've already been on
more than now we haven't got it in the
list we haven't really gone to the list
yet we were talking about testing john
damn list yeah man i was gonna show you
my [ __ ] testosterone badger
[Laughter]
he got his little box yesterday i told
the whole story about going to the damn
coffee what is that on the top it looks
like a little oh it's a it's a
mortar and pestle for for far away it
looks like a coffee cup
i told a whole [ __ ] story about look
at all these drugs
going down to the [ __ ] florida
[ __ ]
hormone clinic in the hormone clinic
with all the [ __ ]
that's only like it's only like a mile
or two from our house
and it's it was florida as [ __ ] man you
would have [ __ ] loved it that was
dealing with all these goddamn
legal drug dealers [ __ ] trying to
tell me all kinds of [ __ ]
hormone therapies and [ __ ] steroid
treatments and human growth hormone and
all kinds of [ __ ] we can hook you up
we're gonna jack you up
you're in great shape and you're old you
got them to lose
you're only going to live another 25.
they didn't tell you you were older
no no they weren't another doctor i kind
of did that doctor kind of did
the doctor they probably said in a nice
way said it in a nice way
i said it's the shape that you're in and
at your age
you know if i can you know we can
[ __ ] we can [ __ ] help you
we can make you bigger you're stronger
and [ __ ] you don't have as much to
lose because [ __ ] that kind of [ __ ]
you haven't been banging yourself up
with all kinds of [ __ ] androgens and
[ __ ]
steroids you're kind of like a prime
candidate like a prime candidate because
you know haven't
you didn't come from a long history of
abuse of [ __ ]
steroidal compounds so they're just like
[ __ ]
you can do whatever you want whatever
you want
you should have said that you got that
what's the point you guys still got a
lot of gas in the tank yeah
i could you know you haven't torn your
liver up you know
by taking [ __ ] well i don't know
about
[Laughter]
you that no idea what they're talking
about i know what was you know [ __ ]
my liver is probably
they got dicks they got dudes out there
that's that
at 17 years old we're taking [ __ ]
gigantic
cycles of [ __ ] all kinds of dangerous
[ __ ] well you know
experimental [ __ ] steroids and then
they were drinking on top of that and
doing drugs and by the time they're 50
they're [ __ ] shot
well there's no more [ __ ] gas in the
tank ask arnold
there's tila what's up t we were talking
about
well that's the thing i was showing
everybody my hormone therapy
that's right there's some florida [ __ ]
here [ __ ] t
went down went down and got my [ __ ]
yeah he's got my dreams he was very
excited about it i took my first
injection yesterday
it's just just starting to kick in takes
about three weeks for it to take its
full effect
he woke up this morning he's like i feel
really weird
[Laughter]
it's kind of like it kind of reminded me
of when i used to smoke you that you
haven't smoked in a long time you take a
little drag and you're like oh
yeah all that testosterone's like
sometimes i get super super drunk if i'm
out at the club and like if somebody has
if somebody because we have a couple
friends that still smoke and if somebody
has a smoke that i'm
that they'll give me she'll get drunk
and take a drag off that cigarette yeah
i'll be like yeah
it's a [ __ ] and then he gets mad
well they usually wait till he goes to
the bathroom and they're just like here
girl
i was like you want a dollar and i was
like
cigarettes had a huge grip on me they
did yeah well you smoked a lot longer
than i did i smoked a lot longer yeah i
spoke for five
i had probably smoked one up for eight
or nine years when i had my
and not like super regular yeah but you
know t i was making comments about
[ __ ] uh
uh the free state of jones in jones
county mississippi
uh that's the movie you need to see i
don't know if you've seen that yet
it's on netflix that's my people
[Laughter]
but my dad was friends with the
surviving knight
family right there [ __ ] you'll see
what i'm talking about when you see the
movie
yeah it's a good one those that's all
kind of like i said it's a time
commitment because it's like two hours
and twenty minutes it's all kind of like
that was and yeah you might like that
movie
it's got a lot of african-american
history in it
yeah it's a yeah it's a good it's a good
place and it wasn't known until recently
and it's in yeah like you said it's
something that
doesn't really get brought up a lot in
historical because like you said it's
mostly local history it's kind of like a
yeah like a weird footnote to like civil
war reconstruction era
kind of history yeah and it didn't play
along with the [ __ ] narrative
that mainstream education wanted to
[ __ ] spin
like with mcconaughey yeah like yeah
matthew mcconaughey
matthew mcdonough and he got in that
dude that was from um green was it
called green mile
green book green book that's right green
mile if you haven't seen green book you
need to see that one too that was a
[ __ ] great movie
i liked green book and that dude that
was the same dude from predators
he played yeah he was in that dude he
was he was the best i feel like like i
said he's having a moment he's been
yeah he was that black dude that was in
that [ __ ] that that
that the predator abducted from the dead
damn what was it the death squad and
cereal the sierra
leone and death squad he was one of them
[ __ ]
they had him up there fighting the
predator evidently
they say i don't know if it's true he's
going to be the new blade
and man i hope that's true he would be a
good blade he'd make a really good blade
yeah you'd have to put on some weight
but he could do it
he could do it he said that's the thing
that's kind of like in your contract
it's like look you have to play the
superhero character you have to put on
like x amount of muscle because that's
always
you know they always ask him to do that
yeah he goes uh oh on the testosterone
you're feeling different
i'm on three different things actually
there's estrogen blocker
testosterone and then i'm gonna go on a
pituitary gland
uh [ __ ] drug that activates your
pituitary gland it starts up
a lot of your [ __ ] all all over
[ __ ] hormonal [ __ ]
production um first day i didn't feel
anything today i
just felt kind of like uh like you need
to stretch
you know if you ever i feel like healing
like it's a
slight tingling feeling and a little bit
more of a positive attitude
a little more energy but it's very kind
of superficial right now it kind of
feels like when i was taking sarms
but they say that it takes about three
weeks before you really feel it kicking
in because it
it has to build up in your system it got
me on a [ __ ]
pretty big dose a dose that if you were
to give it to a healthy guy in his
20s he'd [ __ ] roid out at 200
milligrams a week that's [ __ ] big
that's that's
250 is about that's a [ __ ] big dose
pro bodybuilder be on about 700.
your average young dude if he was
[ __ ] kind of you know he's 30
maybe 25 and his t is low they usually
give him
something along the lines of like
[ __ ] 50 or 100 so
it's a good size dose like the doctor
said he says man you only have 20 25
years left anyway and you're in good
shape here for the bam
he's next military so you can tell me
the truth well yeah he was a military
doctor
v8 you know it's weird i think about
that sometimes because like if you don't
know i'm 48.
so sometimes i think to myself man
i could live another 30 40 years
god that seems like a long time no it
seems like nothing to me
god seems like time goes by so fast 10
years seems like nothing we've been
we've been we've known each other for 10
years yeah and it just [ __ ] flew by
you know i don't know is that i don't
know it just seems like a long time
but i don't know maybe that's just me
it's all in your like perception of it i
guess
[ __ ] it's weird because i feel like [ __ ]
goes by real quick but then
[ __ ] goes by real slow too yeah
i don't know i'm a weird person and i
and i kind of feel like
it was weird because okay so like when
we went to my mom's house because
remember a couple weeks ago we said we
weren't going to do the sunday show
because
we went to visit my mama over in ocala
because my sister was here
so we went to my mom's house and my mom
she's so cute
she's like every single letter you guys
have sent to me every single thing i put
them in like little individual
plastic boxes so she has these plastic
boxes for each kid because i have three
siblings that are younger
and every single letter that we've sent
her every single thing that we've
centered like every present everything
everything
is in this plastic box and for some
reason
she was like i want everybody to look at
their boxes so she gave me my box
and it had like all these letters from
you know that i had sent her like a long
time ago like back in the [ __ ]
90s and early 2000s and stuff and it was
just like really really
it was really weird to like read these
letters and cards and [ __ ] that
like that that i had sent her because i
feel like i'm not
that person anymore and i don't really
have any connection with that person i
know it was me but it's like
i don't know this is what i said you
know i've said this before on the show
i'm not a real like nostalgic person
so sometimes you show me a letter
that was written by me like 15
20 years ago and i'm just like who the
[ __ ] is this i don't
like i don't recognize it like i sort of
remember writing it but
not really alright sis we'll see you
yeah i saw that it's like you know
come back later we'll probably still be
here i haven't even got into any of the
[ __ ] that i wanted to talk about yeah
yeah t that's the one uh free state of
jones and it's uh you can see it for
free on it's on netflix netflix
okay um then you're talking about
rebooting blade
um then tina says she loves historical
features if it's done so well this has
done super well there's a lot of
historical
um uh a lot of historians
like i said told you this before a lot
of historians consulted for this movie
and this movie was done because a friend
of mine that i grew up with
in in jones mississippi did all the
research he was a historian at
university uh
ole miss university and we grew up
hearing legends about newt knight
and later on when my boy grew up to
become a professor down there at ole
miss
he researched this whole case through
all the [ __ ] what records survived
and they put all this together based on
witnesses that witness
writings that survived about this
[ __ ]
it was like a slave uprising mixed with
confederate veterans that had run from
the war
they were over it because they were over
that [ __ ]
because this
the civil war that the secession and the
civil war
was kind of a conspiracy made by very
rich plantation owners
and they didn't want to give up their
plantations they want to lose their
business
it'd have been all right if they wanted
to go out and fight for it but no no no
no
they [ __ ] took the poor um
yeah so like the the poor [ __ ] like
every war ever
they put poor people who were [ __ ] um
farming they took them and made them
fight that war and they were the ones
that were already in competition against
these plantations they couldn't survive
against these plantations
because how are you going to survive
against slave wage
how are you going to survive against
slave wages you can't so
yeah they didn't have wages there's no
way you have been competing against that
when you're a slave they don't pay you
though so what it did was is it just
um it just [ __ ] depressed the
southern economy and just made everybody
[ __ ] poor
and then they told them to go out and
fight the war and that's what it was all
about
like and you can see why a lot of people
like yeah yeah
and then and then the movie gets into
after the war what happened in
in in in during reconstruction
uh there was like a low-level civil
conflict that went on
all the way up to the 1960s that's what
my family came out of it was a [ __ ]
long long war
like a civil war it went all around for
a hundred [ __ ] years
and um i came from
southern republicans and it'll explain
the difference between dixiecrats and
southern republicans
southern republicans were anti-slavery
dixiecrats were pro-slavery and
segregation and it explains kind of like
why that happened
and they basically just beat the black
people over a period of 100 years
they beat them down into voting democrat
to make segregation happen because black
people had to be safe from the clan
so they made them [ __ ] vote for
segregation over time
it was and they don't want to talk about
that in the history books all that
shit's been erased but [ __ ]
we brought it back we're telling
everybody about it
tila is asking is the new candyman going
to be a reboot or a sequel it's actually
a sequel
um because you were following the
exploits at least
what i saw from the trailer you're
following the exploits you know that
the little kid that was rescued from the
um from the
fire in the first candyman he's grown up
now
and they also as far as i know got the
same actor that played his mom
um so this is gonna be a sequel that's
what i could determine from
the trailer please correct me if i'm
wrong but it's not a reboot it's a
sequel
to the original i don't know if tony
todd is gonna be in it
i hope he is because he's rad but you
know
uh some people are skeptical skeptical
saying that
how could blade be good in today's
hollywood i totally [ __ ] feel you
hollywood i know it might be let me
finish what i'm saying
hollywood and disney they are [ __ ] all
right i'm going to the bathroom but they
quit
but they might they might get the right
guy on it
it all depends on [ __ ] all depends on
who they choose as writers
and who they choose as directors but um
if they do a retro style blade
movie that actor that they have
[ __ ] slated to cover blade evidently
if it's the guy that they say it is
he'd make a good blade like i said he'd
have to he'd have to bulk up a little
bit hit the gym
do a few cycles or do what he has to do
to get his [ __ ] hormones right
um now that'd be a great [ __ ] blade
because you know batman is going suck
they're working on a batman movie that
shit's gonna [ __ ] suck
um and i [ __ ] had it with disney
uh i think disney has [ __ ] shot
themselves in the foot
i think that's going to unravel on them
pretty quick
some people are saying well what they
did here you know
firing these people and talking all this
[ __ ] and everything they're dividing
their [ __ ] crowd
but the problem is is that the one that
the the
the customers that they're that they're
getting rid of are the ones that we're
paying
the ones that are doing all the crying
they don't [ __ ] pay they don't see
the movies
it's all just twitter mob [ __ ] so
it could very quickly unravel on disney
restaurant
oh more says they might make it closer
to the comic book which you know
that might be good actually um so i
don't know what he was talking about
because i had to go to like
the bathroom but you know what i mean um
i i don't really want to go off too much
into that direction
but i guess we can finally start talking
about because
i think it was mango that recommended
that we do
our favorite horror movies now as i
mentioned at the top
part of this show i put a lot of thought
into this you guys
and it was really really hard i was
initially going to pick
like i don't know i can't do top 20 i
just can't
so i was gonna do top 100 i started
doing that and then it's like it wasn't
working out
and then so i broke it down by decades
and then even that was too many and it
was like i was having a hard time
winning
everything down so what i did was i did
a top 20
from like the 50s and before
because i haven't seen i mean i've seen
a lot of movies from that era but a lot
of them are not my favorites
um you know so i kind of just kind of
went at all that even then i had to take
[ __ ] out
and then from the 1960s onward i did top
20s
for every decade and even that i'm
saying right now was very very difficult
particularly for the 70s and 80s where i
had to cut out like half of my list
in both even the 90s was kind of hard
and i'm not like a big fan of 90s horror
but i had way too many movies on that
list too so i had to like take a bunch
of them out
so as soon as tom comes back hopefully
um
we'll start talking about the horror
movies also i want to talk about
you guys so what ended up happening so
we've been watching i don't know if you
guys like if you have netflix
they just put up a new docu-series about
um
elisa lamb it's kind of about the good
it's the cecil hotel
like in general it's four it's four
episodes right and then they're about
three four and um it's mostly about the
elisa lamb case but they kind of thread
some other [ __ ] about the seasonal hotel
in there it's like it's
entertaining it is it's really
interesting and they go a lot
into kind of the um internet web sleuth
kind of community because like they have
[ __ ]
uh john lorden on there from uh brain
scratch they have stephanie harlow on
there who i watch a lot
and uh so they have like a lot of [ __ ]
about
on there about how like everybody got a
little um
too excited about the [ __ ] and like some
bad [ __ ] ended up happening so i like
that they went into that
so i want to talk about that and i want
to talk about this stupid stupid stupid
documentary we watched it random last
night
it was on what hulu uh what was it what
you talking about
that nostradamus thing that was hulu i
think it was on hulu okay so
we ended up watching just completely
randomly this [ __ ]
history channel documentary about
nostradamus or
or specifically about nostradamus's
thing about like the antichrist like the
three antichrists and all that [ __ ]
so we ended up watching that and it was
the most ridiculous thing what i want to
say is most ridiculous thing but it's up
there with the most ridiculous thing so
i don't talk about that too but let's
talk about like the horror movies first
or where
did you have like something else you
wanted to like add about um
tina was saying yeah tila i believe they
need to you talk about republicans and
democrats i think they're both out of
date
she says they need a third one i don't
think they need the third one they just
yeah they do they need a third one
they're the both of those are played out
they're both serve [ __ ]
the oligarchs and and and they both
serve big corporations they're not about
us anymore
and they're bullshitting what they're
saying they don't really believe in it's
the shell game stuff
they're politicians i don't trust any of
those goddamn politicians anymore it's
all
fake fake they don't work for us they
work for them
just saying okay go ahead i want to get
mad well yeah i don't want to get mad
i'm in the middle of this
this is supposed to be fun yeah it's
supposed to be fun yeah yeah zach says
if hereditary isn't on your list i'll
probably cry i think you will be very
happy
yeah i'm gonna get another drink in a
bit okay i'll finish this out first
okay so as i said what i did with this
list
was that from 1900 to 1960
i picked my top 20 from that time period
because there were a lot of movies i
liked from then but it's like there
weren't quite as many as like later
um so you want to go down you want to go
down
like the [ __ ] okay well here's the
deal what i'm gonna tell the audience i
didn't make my own list because i trust
jenny's list i'm not a big
ho also also you're i know most of the
[ __ ]
i'm lazy too but also i know that most
of the [ __ ] she's
we will like most of the same movies all
right
we like most of the same movies so her
list is going to probably look like my
list anyway
i don't know well yeah maybe to an
extension more about charlotte movies
well and a lot of [ __ ] on there you
might not have seen too
we'll see we'll see and like i said
please keep in mind if like you forget a
movie i'll throw one of mine
if my favorite [ __ ] from the 60s or the
70s and 80s or 90s is not in there it's
not because i don't love that movie
it's just that i was really really
trying to winnow it down to 20. and i
felt really really bad because i had to
take out a lot of movies that i really
wanted to keep in there but i just
didn't want this to be like [ __ ]
seven hours long
that's all i'm saying so as i said from
1900 to 1960 so like you know or
actually 1959 i guess so these are my
top 20.
now i'm going from 20 down to one okay
these not necessarily it was hard to put
them in order
it's you know everybody that's into
horror movies this is like very
difficult
so number 20 i'm going to go with the
phantom carriage
from 1921. [ __ ] i don't even know that
one oh
is this a silent movie this is the deal
um i did
i have a series like casket of [ __ ]
dr kelly i'm not we'll i'll get there
okay this is i'm at number 20. chill out
phantom carriage um it might have been
based on a short story i'm not just not
cabinet but
casket i you know what i didn't even
bring that up
you accused me of picking on you i'm not
even bringing it up i i knew what you
said
you were picking on me as i said is a
good part of the show
that's a good portion of the show i like
to pick on you yeah
it's fun i noticed that yeah she did she
waits for me to [ __ ] reach a moment
of weakness when i'm [ __ ] drunk well
yeah
yeah well it's only fun to pick on you
and you're vulnerable because
because i [ __ ] poke pookie running
across my nuts in the middle of the
night while i'm sleeping
it's yeah it's it's the same principle
yeah because you're
you're you're bigger than us and you're
like more powerful than us
so i swear to god that cat knows what
nuts are she does
she stomps on him [ __ ] when she runs
across and then laughs
it's very purposeful jenny's seen it
happen
yeah it's on purpose isn't it she thinks
it's very very funny
oh my god okay this reminded me so
remember how
we said on the show that pookie talks to
herself in the mirror
oh yeah she jumps up on uh the
bathroom counter and she looks at
herself in the mirror very deliberately
and she goes
like she's talking to herself right i
saw this video today it was like
recommended on my [ __ ] youtube [ __ ]
because you know i watch a lot of cat
videos okay i'm just admitting that
right now so i get like
i get all the jackson and i subscribe to
jackson galaxy and all that kind of
stuff
so i get this recommendation today
uh percy what was the cat's name perseus
i think perseus the cat talks to himself
in the mirror
i was like oh my god pookie does that so
i watched it
and it was it was interesting because
perseus
he was kind of like this tabby like this
orange kitty
and he wasn't i don't know if he wasn't
really like looking at himself in the
mirror
he was sitting on the bathroom counter
and he was like in front of the mirror
but he was kind of like looking over
there
and he was making these really bizarre
like
like kind of noises that's not what
pookie does
cats talk to themselves yeah but pokey
jumps up on the bathroom counter
and looks at herself very deliberately
she looks at herself and then she goes
[Music]
like she's talking to the other other
pookie
we call it mary universe spooky i don't
know i don't know if she knows that
that's her
or if she thinks it's another cat she's
not reacting like it's another cat she
knows it's her
i'm pretty sure she knows that's her but
i'm like not
i'm not sure like what she's saying
though i don't know
but so like i was kind of disappointed
in this other video because it's like
the cat was
not one he wasn't looking at himself
directly in the mirror he was kind of
looking sideways
sort of like part of the time and then
he was making those really bizarre
and i kind of thought to myself well
that cat maybe it thinks it's another
cat
i don't get the impression that pookie
thinks that's another cat i think she
thinks that that's her
and i'm not sure what she's saying to
herself
but she seems like she doesn't react the
same way that she reacts to another cat
because sometimes we have other cats
like come out the porch or whatever
and she sees them and she reacts to them
in a particular way and she makes like a
very particular
like meow or a particular noise that's
not the noise that she's making when she
looks in the mirror
i kind of feel like she knows and the
weird thing too is that she looks at
herself in the mirror
and talks and then she looks back at us
or looks at us in the mirror and like
kind of looks at us like
do you see this [ __ ] she kind of looks
like that so i don't really know if it's
the same thing
and like i said i'm trying to get it on
video but she always does it at night
and you know so i there's not a lot of
like night vision
[ __ ] going on you're all right you got
everything all right
so what i say number twenty phantom
carriage you didn't see that it's good
though museum
and honestly 1921 this had some pretty
kick-ass like special effects i think it
i feel like it might have been swedish
i could be wrong about that but um it's
basically like this carriage that comes
it's like when you're gonna die here's
this phantom carriage comes the list is
like 10
10 movies it's 20. that's why oh [ __ ]
all right
it's gonna be a six hour movie no it's
not it's not all right
number 19. i'm gonna go with the wolfman
from 1941 you've seen that right yeah
with launching yeah um
been a long time though i mean i love
all the universal movies the wolf man is
probably my least favorite
comes up with mirror in the bathroom
she knows that song oh my god i love you
must be in the sky music
yeah okay i love you why aren't you the
[ __ ] hanging out over here in florida
you you and your man you couldn't think
of that they couldn't come in they were
in the bathroom
oh no that was i thought it was the jam
the jam the jam yeah
but yeah um zach says yeah swedish oh
okay
i'm drunk and i totally called it really
influenced burgman
and you we'll have we'll see some ingmar
bergman later on on the list you know
um yeah so number 19 the wolf man from
1941. like
like i said i like that movie that was
but there was a lot to pick from
number 18 this one might be a little bit
out there
hands of orlac 1924 i don't remember
that one
this is about a dude and he's a pianist
and he's in a train accident that
somehow
severs his hands if that's it so he
gets hands grafted onto him but they
were a murderer's hands
and it's good it's um do i
what's this seem this was a silent yeah
this was a silent film
and i liked the ambiguity because you
weren't sure if
the murder hands were possessing him
or if he just because he knew that they
were murder hands
that that was like [ __ ] his mind up
it's good it's like seriously it's a
good movie it really is
it was silent i haven't seen it i know
you haven't well
like a lot of these probably haven't
yeah um so yeah hands of orlak you so go
watch it i think i watch it on youtube
it's free
because like i said it came out in 1924
it's probably in the public domain at
this time says too hot and humid to move
down to florida
she loves those beaches though you just
got to get used to it you get used to it
it's yeah you're used to it
i mean honestly in the summer you just
have to stay inside
and not go outside for any reason i
didn't go out this year the past couple
years during the
i stayed away for like two years i can't
handle it anymore
i got this [ __ ] damn i got all this
hormonal therapy that's gonna [ __ ]
bring me back out of the [ __ ] shell
i'll be out there i'm gonna go down in a
[ __ ] pool
yeah we don't have a pool but the
community the community has a pool
it's nice i've been there around the
pool have you ever
what's that never been down there i've
got the [ __ ] complex has a pool i've
never been to it and a clubhouse
i've been down there a lot i've been
down there and then i'm gonna ride
motorcycles this summer
it's a nice pool a couple more couple
more weeks we're gonna see we're gonna
see it's all gonna [ __ ] come back
i'm gonna feel a lot better they told me
i s when you s when i saw them [ __ ] t
numbers i was like oh [ __ ] no wonder i
feel like [ __ ]
well that's what when you showed me the
[ __ ] i was like well that explains why
because honestly i told him i was like
look i was afraid
but he was gonna go down there yeah and
they were gonna be like your
testosterone level's fine
so i don't really know what you're
whining about and so i thought it was
gonna be like that but like when he
showed me the [ __ ] i was like oh dude
yeah oh dude i was like well that
explains a lot testosterone of like a
[ __ ] 70-something year old man
i mean considering that you're actually
not as bad as i
would have expected weight working out
as i would have expected
that it took forever to heal up but in
that negativity it started about two
years ago when my dad
[ __ ] had all those surgeries i
started just getting depression kicked
in
i think i think [ __ ] that affected
not only my mind but just my whole entry
consistent
yeah i mean it started to get real
negative
yeah it's a spiral the other other
veterans told me
the same thing happened to them they
come out of service and they go into the
spiral
well and i was going to say this before
i feel like
maybe i don't know if women have this
but like dudes have a thing
where when you're not young and
quote unquote useful you anymore
um it's almost kind of like you feel
like oh i don't have any purpose anymore
and they kind of like go into these
death spirals or whatever
and it's like i feel like i don't know
like women don't really have that
i guess because i mean from my point of
view i'm not speaking for all women
obviously but from my point of view i've
always felt irrelevant so i don't really
care if i'm irrelevant or not so it's
just kind of like i don't know
it doesn't bother me all that much it's
like yeah i'm getting old and just like
no one cares
i don't care it doesn't bother me i
don't know why it doesn't bother me
but i feel like that that's something
that like a lot of dudes from
yeah my grandpa's my dad's generation i
think it's all men as soon as they
retire
from their jobs they would drop dead yep
and i was like holy crap they didn't
have any hobbies they didn't have any
other like identity like other than
their jobs and like
so as soon as that was gone they didn't
have anything else to live for and they
just like croaked
t if you mask 40 or over have that
[ __ ] checked out have him
do some blood work look at this look at
what his [ __ ] bio-availability
and his [ __ ] total testosterone are
it only costs a couple hundred bucks
gotta check that [ __ ] out
if that [ __ ] is under put him on
treatment he'll feel a lot better
i mean i feel pretty good right now but
they say three weeks into it it's just
night and day
we'll see but i mean like you like you
said you only had the injection
yesterday
yeah i could feel a difference but yes
it's they say three weeks into it
because it's so much
so much of it is built up in your body
and it's been like doing its job
they say that you [ __ ] feel like a
[ __ ] million bucks and
as i said in my experience um
even though women have a bad reputation
it's like oh they have
periods and they're like emotionally
volatile or whatever i have never um
found that in my experience that's
usually dudes that have
that kind of up and down kind of crazy
thing um women are a lot more
kind of stable well you guys go ahead
and tell yourself that no i'm just
saying that like it just in my personal
experience i don't know if that's like
true or not but uh
evolutionary from the in an evolutionary
way
in way all right men were not designed
doesn't matter what species i'm talking
about males of other species too
male ants or not mainly it's all ants
male dogs and male a male lions and [ __ ]
they didn't live long
they didn't have to live long they lived
a short dangerous life they reproduced a
few times
did a lot of fighting trying to get rid
of the other males so they
could impregnate some female and when
their [ __ ] started to get weak they died
well because they were no longer used
they're no longer useful i mean they
weren't they didn't need to be around to
like raise children or
like do anything that was a woman's job
so that's kind of like bread in to the
male
genome we gotta keep the other species
because we got a lot of [ __ ] to do but
this is 2021. you can
[ __ ] yeah but evolution doesn't work
that fast no no but you can counter
counteract it without exogenous
functioning sure hormones and stuff
because now they know how the body works
so you can counteract what evolution has
done to you
eventually i think they'll be able to
make artificial bodies or download
the human mind into a digital matrix and
you'll live on man
i hope that they do that i believe you
will live on in a
you know if i could pop my brain into
like some other body that i chose like a
[ __ ] avatar
like i am totally i think what they'll
do they'll download your consciousness
into something like an internet and the
internet
from your point of view will become a
heaven-like realm
yeah if you want to come out of it you
can inhabit a synthetic android type
body
or even or or maybe inhabit a ship or a
airplane or a spaceship or anything like
that and you can be that for a while
tom's childhood dream of being in an
airplane when i was
six i wanted to be a goddamn airplane
that was what do you want me when you
grow up an airplane they [ __ ] look at
me like
[ __ ] crazy airplanes but [ __ ]
you'll do [ __ ] like that i'm going to be
a robot
then you go back into the [ __ ]
internet and be now
some people will say well that's
cheating and that's immortality and
god doesn't want that it's not
immortality because
is eventually over the millions or
billions of years that internet says
that internet will be destroyed through
a supernova or
something like that you will eventually
die you'll just die later so think of it
think of it as life extension sure you
know
because i'm not afraid of death you know
i've had out-of-body experiences and
near-death experiences and motorcycle
accidents i do believe in a
i do believe in another realm people
will call it a heaven-like experience
but you'll eventually go there that [ __ ]
can wait
it doesn't care if you live on another
couple thousand years
that's nothing like i said i'm not
concerned like if they come up with some
[ __ ] they're like hey you want to pop
your brain into this like [ __ ] robot
and be like
sure yeah sure if you lived an
additional
two years 5 000 years or even an
additional 5 million years
the universe wouldn't know the
difference wouldn't care neither would
heaven
that's what i mean the universe does not
care about you so you might as well just
do
get that bonus time sure might as well
do whatever you want to do
yep universe does not care about you
yeah so but in a way that's like
liberating yeah i find it liberating
yeah i believe in an afterlife
but you don't have to go if you don't
want to if the technology says
no we can make you live 10 000 years
longer do it
yeah okay heaven can wait it won't know
the difference because in the
in the grand scheme of things even 10
million years is still
nothing i mean people have a hard time
wrapping their mind around a concept
called deep
time well there's life so
your life span is a blink it's a flash
compared to how long the universe will
last
sure so it won't matter and like i said
the universe doesn't care about you
right
and like i said i'm not i'm not saying
that to be me and i'm i find that a very
liberating concept
because it gives you a lot of freedom
you know what i mean
in that uh everybody's never talking now
um where was i okay so 18 hands of orlac
1924 and some people said because i
think it was like remade or
you know under different titles but yeah
see the original i liked it it was a
silent movie
um number 17 i'm gonna go with uh dead
of night from 1945 which uh was an
anthology movie if i remember correctly
also uh number 16 white zombie
1932 bella lugosi one of the very
because you guys know i talked about
this on our serpent in the rainbow
review yeah i [ __ ] love old school
zombie movies
serpent and the red white zombie was
probably the first one
serpent and the rainbow was good it was
a lot better than i remembered it i saw
it when i was a kid
in high school it was a lot better than
i remembered it i didn't really
talk about myself but it's good it's a
good haitian zombie movie
yeah and like i said they didn't really
make a lot of those
but white zombie was one of the first
ones and bella lugosi was in it
uh very good number 15 i'm gonna go with
knight of the demon from 1957.
which i feel like doesn't get seen left
or under seen so
you know check that [ __ ] out i don't
remember that one um
yeah i know i don't remember number 14
i'm gonna go with the man who laughs
1928 this was the inspiration
for the joker if you guys didn't know
oh i've seen pictures of that dude he
looks just like the joker
well that's where they got the idea from
yeah yeah yeah the man who left
i don't know if i'd call it a horror
movie i guess it's a horror movie but it
kind of hug
i don't know it's kind of hard exactly
classified
but yes photographs that do with that
big little [ __ ] toothy mouth
in that [ __ ] hair and you're like man
it looks like the joker
you look stupid because that's where
they got the idea of the joker from
that's where
when i was a kid growing up [ __ ] the
joker to me was caesar romero and the
old [ __ ] joker serial you know the
old tv series
from the 60s and i i didn't know what to
make of that as a kid that was like some
[ __ ]
cocaine inspired [ __ ] sure like if
somebody was doing cocaine and lsd
they'd come up with that
batman television movie i want that [ __ ]
on blu-ray
okay i'm gonna buy that [ __ ] we have
amazon you can buy it right now if you
want to
live on no no no no no no i want a hard
copy
i want to see that because that had some
hotties on that man that had [ __ ]
eartha kit
and then [ __ ] that also had what was
the other bat woman
there were two bat women earth the kid
was i think the first one
and then the second one was that red
head you had to be a cute chick to be on
[ __ ] batman the old batman well yeah
and then the dudes that they had were on
there were total freakazoids
like cesar romero romero was [ __ ]
that that dude was like he snorted five
lines
every time he [ __ ] and then [ __ ]
adam west and [ __ ] adam west and
[ __ ] robin
that was some [ __ ] kind of kinky [ __ ]
there julie newmar somebody julie
newmark that's right
god that woman was gorgeous she was um
she was actually yeah she was gorgeous
and then then you had that whole goddamn
thing with the [ __ ]
batman and robin and is this a
homosexual relationship what is this
[ __ ] you know what i mean you got
batman with this cute boy in his mask
running around his little shorty shorts
with his little booty shoes on and then
he's judging
like that's but come on tell us what it
is come out and tell us what it is well
you could
do that back then okay all right come on
they're like
and there was all these superheroes with
these running around these little boys
in the comic books during that period
that's what i mean well i feel like
there was a lot of [ __ ] man suspicious
i mean suspicious just in the sense that
you couldn't get away with that kind of
[ __ ] back then so you had to like kind
of code everything and you had to kind
of like you know
got a grown man running around but if
you were into that kind of [ __ ] you were
like oh
i don't know man a grown man running
around with a 10 year old boy through
the whole [ __ ] comic book
nowadays you get arrested for that well
it was the difference that's some
epstein [ __ ]
it was a different time dude i mean ten
is that's a little yeah
i'm talking [ __ ] i'm just having fun
people because i don't
that's not what it was i knew exactly
what david june says that's why they had
aunt harriet so people didn't think they
were gay
yeah well it really was i was around
during that time you know what i mean
[ __ ] my friends i wasn't too much
into comic books my friends like in
third grade were getting all that [ __ ]
and in back in the 70s the old comic
books were coming out going away and the
new comic books were coming in it was
like fantastic four and
[ __ ] you know galacticus and all that
kind of [ __ ] from
and they were getting rid of the [ __ ]
boys sidekicks but the reason why they
were doing is they were trying to get
boys to buy the goddamn
comic book and they would feel like they
were included alongside
with this yeah i kind of feel like what
they were doing there wasn't really
anything similar
they were just kind of like hey we need
a kid
character right so the boy reads so the
kid feels like he's
next insert himself yes that's all it
was so a lot of people have [ __ ]
nothing nefarious we're just all
perverts yeah it's like
it's just it's just funny to look at it
from the other side
like if that was [ __ ] was really going
on you guys would be in jail
well yeah run around i mean this is my
ward
you know my award your award huh my
houseboy
yeah my houseboy which like i said
nowadays people be like
yeah okay but yeah well i think but you
can see how it came about
it wasn't necessarily i think there were
many
little [ __ ] i think there were many a
little gay boy that maybe misinterpreted
some of that stuff but well look
everybody's going to bring their own
experiences they're going to bring their
own [ __ ] to it that's the
that's the awesome thing and sometimes
the problematic thing
about fiction is that you bring your own
experiences to it and if you have like
some different experiences
to what the authors intended yeah then
shit's going to read a lot different to
you than maybe
the person that wrote and god damn
they're like 20
julie newmars written in there everybody
jumps up yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay she was she was cute
i mean when i was like
when i was a uh you know [ __ ] six or
seven or eight
i was just [ __ ] drooling over that
woman
just like god that was so cute yeah
because back in those days full grown
beautiful women were
far out of your reach you could just
yeah you could just of course you're
like
that's like mom you're like seven and
you're like going [ __ ] god i wish i
could oh god
this is a god i wish i could have that
but you know it's just like uh
that's true though a lot of people don't
believe that but when i was a little boy
i was trying to hit everything that's
right [ __ ] i was
so don't even like tell me about that
right i was [ __ ] i was
[ __ ] deborah harry and everything
[ __ ]
big into deborah harry i would i would
seriously i would have hit deborah
harrisburg
big into that chick from land of the
lost holly
but then uh when we went back and
watched lana lost and holly was into her
[ __ ] so-called brother on the line
i love it and i realized like how much
that girl was just [ __ ] dripping
wet for [ __ ] will she loved himself
it was just so obvious
oh my god oh well really like it's you
could
keep your [ __ ] connections yeah
i didn't realize it when i was a kid
when i was watching it but like he's
watching now i'm like
like god damn yeah and the dude the
the dude playing well is getting
obviously getting kind of embarrassed i
could see that he was
like it's a weird situation to be in
because he's like look i'm kind of
flattered but also i'm kind of weirded
out because yeah i'm like 19 or 20.
well in the 70s it wouldn't have
mattered i mean it was still illegal it
was still illegal but in the 70s they
didn't impress
charges on [ __ ] like that then [ __ ]
that that's how
[ __ ] especially not in the hollywood
area that's
that's how [ __ ] old [ __ ] roman
polanski got in [ __ ] trouble with the
[ __ ] [ __ ] that he was doing
because she was 14. she was about 14.
they were doing that and there were
drugs involved and
it was just another time i mean you know
[ __ ] half the damn family me
if half of the damn manson family going
around
killing people and taking drugs and
having big old [ __ ] sex orgies half
of them were under the age of six well
and the cults that we're going to be
talking about on saturday's show
the source family um there was a lot of
that going on too well
well the thing about it okay like i said
so the 60s were a magical time
thank you and it was kind of a thing
where
man you were like 13 and you didn't like
you weren't like down with your parents
like they were like [ __ ] bringing you
down man so it's like you just
[ __ ] ran off to california or
whatever and you joined a cult
and then somehow you ended up marrying
a 50 year old guru
yeah so you wouldn't get so he wouldn't
get charged with statutory rape
it was a whole thing scott i do know
scott ryan
talking about batman and boy wonder he
goes it was a mentorship
yes it was it was a mentor
sure i mean
but i don't know am i just being the
pervert i don't know but i'm just being
a pervert because
i mean i don't know if like i'm into
like [ __ ]
i like all that like [ __ ] gay porn
man so it's like you know i think all
women like gay porn
paul go it's a very large audience yeah
maybe people will be surprised
women love gay porn paul moore says oh
man i dream of genie and big witch
i was for sure into milfs when i was a
kid hell yeah
hell yes i was [ __ ] big into that
that makes me feel better being
like an older [ __ ] no an old broad yeah
an old winch as i am no when i was when
i was a kid i was into older women
although i'm not a middle because i
don't have any children yeah so i'm not
about that
i'm more like a wilf well i'm a wilf
well
what was her name i'm an o wilf an old
woman
yeah you know the um genie
and [ __ ] samantha they were they
weren't that old i think they were in
their [ __ ]
20s uh i think maybe samantha
was in her early 30s wasn't she sam what
was
what was the name of that i don't i
they weren't old they were pretty young
no but
they would have seen those yeah they
would seem old to a little kid
but they weren't that old [ __ ] um
what was their name [ __ ] barbara eden
i think
that time was in her 20s yeah uh
like i said that's but the thing is is
back in the 60s that was
damn near old if you were 30 year old
60s like logan's run man you're 30 years
old yeah yeah you're 30.
go to carousel exactly exactly
oh [ __ ] people didn't live long but not
much was expected out of them isn't that
you leave the service you join a
corporation you make a few cars
they kill you i told you you moved
in suburbs and died when i was growing
up and i remember this very distinctly
so this must have been i was 12. yeah so
i so it was 1984
maybe yeah and i remember being in
school and being like
and they were talking about the year
2000 i was like oh my god in the year
2000 i'm going to be 28
years old holy [ __ ] that feels like so
[ __ ] awesome elizabeth
and i am like 20 years older than that
now
yeah and it's just like so [ __ ] funny
to think about
yeah when i was little like how old that
seemed
joe reminded me it was elizabeth
montgomery that's where your name was
i've
said that name one best part look man
zach can't agree with me the best part
of [ __ ] bewitched
was [ __ ] uncle arthur never [ __ ]
uploaded
yeah alcohol
is [ __ ] funny like don't like don't
look at me
i always had a gay character but they
always kept that [ __ ] down the dow
nobody called it gay though no they
always had one
they always had a gay character they
just didn't call them gay because you
had
you had to be old enough to know you
couldn't say that you couldn't say you
couldn't say that you couldn't say it
yeah which is stupid but whatever you
couldn't say that like back on tv
you couldn't you couldn't even show like
married couples sleeping in the same
[ __ ] bed
back then yeah everyone was so [ __ ]
upset
who is the g who's the king of all gays
poland paul lind is the king of all gays
from the hollywood square zach paul lind
has
you buried in the [ __ ] dirt you would
never measure
oh you would i wouldn't use it he's in
the center square
of like [ __ ] hollywood squares and
he's [ __ ] wrong okay
drunk constantly drunk for like a decade
yeah for a decade they got that [ __ ] in
the center
and he just he had the like the most
barbed wit
it was fantastic oscar wilde couldn't
deal with that [ __ ]
yeah that was like some oscar wilde yeah
and he'd be sitting there and
[ __ ] it was funny because they'd
record all those shows on the same day
they might record 12 shows in a day and
you could see that
he was drunker and drunker as each show
would be sometimes you'd see
him with his glass you see him with his
glass and he'd be putting it down like
that as they ask him because he's hiding
the glass
it was just another time man the 70s
were [ __ ] great
and i'd be a little kid watching this
[ __ ] coming home from school i was just
[ __ ] loving it
i didn't know what i didn't know that
pauline was gay i didn't know what gay
was
but i just [ __ ] it was obvious that
that dude was a
he was like he ran that [ __ ] show
nowadays they would call that throwing
shade
and he was like i was like
yeah and it wasn't and it was all
ad-libbed no
it wasn't scripted and [ __ ] people
that knew him said he was like that and
really he just like gave some like
devastating [ __ ] [ __ ]
and like it was like a devastating
insult but you didn't know it was an
insult until like a couple minutes later
you're like wait
what yeah and that's oh [ __ ] that [ __ ]
would go to the [ __ ] gay bar wearing
a dashiki
did you know that i love it he wore the
cheekies and [ __ ] to the gay bar
yeah which like i said i love that yeah
and also another thing i love
is that he did the voice of templeton
the rat
in [ __ ] charlotte's web which was one
of my favorite
books and also one of my favorite
cartoons when i was a kid
and he did that [ __ ] and i love that
they hired him to do that that's just
that's fantastic that's some gay history
for you fantastic that's some gay
history for you zach go back and go see
your age
go see your ancestors go see your
ancestors that's
that's fantastic he was [ __ ] awesome
yeah he was [ __ ] hilarious zach says
uh
kem says and charles nelson riley yes
yes
yes yes and and rick taylor
oh my god the confetti yeah
this was back before you could say a man
was gay on television
you had to figure it out on your own
they were effective no one would say
that
it's just they had too much class they
had too much class to say it you just
said figure it out on your own you just
couldn't say it though
that's like so funny [ __ ] funny yeah
charles nelson riley
and it's weird too because like a lot of
[ __ ] you know hollywood like big
hollywood actors were gay but they
couldn't
say it lately and you couldn't come out
yeah so they had to like take pictures
like look look at this woman that i'm
with
yeah hey fantastic it's called a
mustache yeah
it's a beard it's not a god
it's a beard so they had to like do this
whole thing it's like they had to do
like
sham marriages and they had to have this
whole [ __ ]
yeah it's just it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous
land [ __ ] um no riley
and a [ __ ] um
oh oh [ __ ] i just said his name [ __ ]
um
i don't know what'd you say taylor
those three guys right there they were
the
they were your guests it's funny yeah
those were those were your gays that
were out
those were the ones that were out they
were they brought them in like okay we
need a gay
they were out of him yeah as in the
sense that they could be
like they could be flamboyant but you
couldn't say something
i have sex with men that was like taboo
yeah but everybody knew
you just couldn't say sure yeah and
[ __ ]
it was a different time man and in a way
i think
weird in a way it made it so weird but
you know what's funny is that it made
for
really good television it made it well
it did it's very good television
because they weren't telling you you had
to figure everything out everything was
innuendo and that was what
everything was your innuendo and yeah
yeah everything was like
coded the innuendo and inside jokes and
all kinds of [ __ ] you couldn't
having certain because you couldn't say
anything outright because you weren't
allowed
having the rules actually they played
with the rules it made the humor even
better
yeah because you're like you had to work
around you had to work around it and
well and sometimes that makes comments
better when you have like limitations
like
yeah them working around it was all part
of the joke
yeah which uh it was [ __ ] it was just
it was i went back and watched another
good oh [ __ ] man we're [ __ ] getting
sidetracked but this is a side track
show
well yeah there's another one you can
see all these shows on youtube
they're all [ __ ] recorded and you can
watch them again hollywood squares was a
good one with paul lynn back in the day
i still love that another one that was
great
was one called the liars [ __ ] i love
that
we just rewatched a lot of that like on
the internet it was [ __ ] good
and all that was like a panel of [ __ ]
like four was betty white on that [ __ ]
she was on a lot of things she is a
national treasure and so was [ __ ]
buddy
and he would be drunk off his ass yeah
and what you did was you had two
contestants
they're betting money they had to bet
who was [ __ ] telling the truth
all right and they would hand a [ __ ]
strange unidentifiable object
to the first celebrity and he would tell
you what it was probably most of the
time it was a vibration well
five five out of six of them were lying
one of them was telling the truth and
you had to figure out which one was
telling truth
all right like what about this object
[ __ ] these
buddy hackie would [ __ ] tell some
[ __ ] lies
the [ __ ] that could come up yeah and
what was funny is that he'd be lying
about the object but then it turned out
that it was true
because he could make the truth sound
like a lie that's how good he was
well see that's what you need for a show
like that yeah he could be telling the
truth but he just sounded like he was
[ __ ] lying
because he knew how to embellish the
truth until it became a lie
and maybe that's maybe that's why they
kept hiring him for that show because
he'd be [ __ ] he was throwing
everybody off the center yeah there's
him and the other guy from hogan's
heroes i forgot what that motherfucker's
name is
bob crane was it no the one that got the
blonde guy
somebody in there oh i know somebody in
the in the uh
comments we'll [ __ ] say they you
could see them [ __ ] lifting [ __ ]
glasses of scotch and then when the
camera hit them
they'd be putting the scotch down
because they would [ __ ] record
10 of them a [ __ ] day like look we
can't expect us to like record all day
and not have any booze
not in the 70s not back in the 70s not
nowadays not in this house then you'd
have like [ __ ] you'd have like
[ __ ]
guests like sammy davis jr showed up
he was good at that kind of [ __ ] too
sometimes they'd have bigger
celebrity guests show up to these things
it's kind of like a like an attraction
and i remember he would be on some of
them shows he was pretty good too
yeah i remember that that's having a
junior showing up yeah because that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] would drink too he was a fun
dude yeah
man he was in like the [ __ ] uh
cannonball run at least
wouldn't him and burt reynolds in the
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] dom deluise and
all those guys captain chaos
one of these days we should do the first
gotta do cannonball run cannonball run
yeah i haven't seen it forever
i was i saw it like a million times that
was good i saw the second one too
i don't remember the second one as much
but i remember the first one it's like i
remember really liking it
yeah so um what's your next one
so where was i okay man who laughs i we
talked about that yeah that's how we
went off on the whole [ __ ] batman
tangent
number 13 is where it was i walked with
a zombie
43 that is also bella lugosi and that's
another like
haitian zombie movie like i said i
love that kind of [ __ ] so you're gonna
do
[ __ ] rocky erickson did a song called
i walked with a zombie based on this
[ __ ] movie as far as i know
but yeah good flick 19 uh
you know 19 whatever what i say 1943
next one number 12 hexane 1922.
this is another silent movie this is a
weird movie because
it's almost kind of like half um i want
to say it was like
swedish or norwegian or something like
that this movie was like half
it almost seemed like it wanted to be a
documentary
about witchcraft but also it wanted to
be a horror movie so it kind of had a
thing
where it was kind of like
it had the imprimatur if i can use that
snotty word
um of being a documentary but it was
also
sort of fictionalized so the thing about
hexane
was that it was kind of like half of it
was kind of like look at here's the
thing about witchcraft and blah blah and
they went a lot into
um how nowadays
which in 1922 was 1922
it's like a lot of stuff that would have
you know a lot of people that would have
been burned at the stake
back in the day of you know the
witchcraft burnings and stuff
it's like that would have been
um seen as witchcraft back then but like
nowadays in the 1920s
you know contemporary with when this
movie was made we
understand now that that is mental
illness
so it's better now than then but it's
like it's really weird because
i don't know this is like a really weird
movie and because it was european
they could get away with a lot of [ __ ]
that probably in the 1920s will not
probably
definitely in the 1920s she would not
have been able to get away with
um there was a lot of nudity that was
like kind of like hey
we're gonna like [ __ ] cook a baby and
we're gonna do this and that
so there's a lot of [ __ ] in here which
if you're coming at it from
hey they would have shown that in the
1920s um
you might be surprised at the [ __ ] they
showed in the 1920s
in europe at least so it's
um i kind of feel like hexan is one of
those movies
where if you're into
horror movies if you're into the history
of horror movies you're interested in it
you kind of need to see it because it's
one of those kind of
iconic films
that i don't know is it there was so
much in it that is
is iconic there's so much in it that
i don't know it's just more people need
to see it so like i said
hexane is my number 12. and that came
out in 1922 as i said
now now my number 11 and like i said it
was really hard for me to like put these
in order so don't get like too
[ __ ] uh you know concerned with what
order i put the [ __ ] in because it was
like really difficult for me to like
[ __ ] what is this
it's a little like granola bar tonight
okay well i can't i don't know it's like
like i might eat one later but we'll see
i just gotta get some in my stomach i
was drinking yeah
so you missed number 12 which was hexane
actually i remember that one yeah yeah
yeah which like i said
you might be shocked because it was
european
because it came out in 1922 you might be
shocked at some of the stuff that they
show
in it um also the cinematography very
nice for 1922 gotta say
um but yeah as you showed it it's about
witchcraft well there's a lot of nudity
there's like you know babies being
killed in it like sacrificed and [ __ ]
it's about witchcraft
right and it's kind of like half
fictional wise [ __ ] and like half
documentary kind of like about
witchcraft
so it's a good one to watch like i said
if you're interested in the history of
cinema at all you should probably watch
xn because it's kind of like
it's an iconic film from like the silent
era so probably you should watch it
number 11 i'm gonna go with invasion of
the body snatchers
1956. i
love pretty much every version of
invasion of the body snatchers
because i don't remember if my 70s one i
might have had to take it off the list
but if i did i'm sorry
because i love the 70s version 50s
version is good too i love this
i like the 70s version better but the
50s version is also good
50s version was kind of like
as it as most horror movies of the 50s
were
kind of like oh my god the comedies are
coming to get us
and they were so it was always kind of
like that but
still good though i mean aliens come and
like taking over people
you can't like [ __ ] you can't beat
that so
you know invasion the body snatcher is
very good from 1956.
number 10 night of the hunter 1955.
dude with the [ __ ] love hate
[ __ ] on the robert mitchum was in that
[ __ ] oh
so good he's like going after those kids
see you haven't seen anything
he hasn't seen anything knight of the
hunter
is a [ __ ] classic from the 50s
everybody see that [ __ ] these are old
movies well yeah this
this first list is from 1900 to 1959
actually okay so
the fact that i don't see you i had to
take some off of this but you know so
yeah 900 1955. number nine
lei diabolique also from 1955
great [ __ ] french thriller about
these two women
like this dude is
so he has a wife and he's cheating on
her
with this mistress it's at this [ __ ]
uh
school or whatever like a boarding
school and
so the wife and the mistress get
together and they're like man we're
gonna kill this [ __ ]
because he sucks and um
[ __ ] ensues um you know they they think
they kill
him they put him in the pool and [ __ ]
but it doesn't it's not quite as simple
as all that
really really good flick so if you
haven't seen ley dab a leak
they remade it i think
they didn't make an english language
version i feel like they made an english
language reversion later on which was
okay but like the original is like way
better
and that was from 1955. number eight i'm
going to say
cat people knight original cappy 42
directed by val luten now if you guys
know anything about horror movies
you will know about what they call the
luton bus
which is it's essentially like a jump
scare
but it's kind of because this was a very
early example of that
because there's a very famous scene in
cat people
where um irina the name of the character
and her whole thing is that when she
gets
sexually aroused and they don't say it
like that in the movie but that's what
they mean
um she turns into she's like a werewolf
but
she turns into like essentially a
panther right
yeah so she tries not to get sexually
aroused because she doesn't want to turn
into a panther and eat people but you
know it happens
um but they're not to get sexually
arrested
think of that chef that's very difficult
very difficult well
i grew up with an artist natasha kinski
one
and that [ __ ] right that's good too i
like i like that one
malcolm mcdowell and natasha and uh you
know i don't i was pretty young but i
was old enough to get sexually aroused
over nintendo kinski
she was [ __ ] cute man real cute
yeah that was a good movie and then we
had
david bowie doing the soundtrack to it
yeah see
these eyes so yeah he did a whole song
called cat people
uh parenthetical putting out fires
but the original is very very good and
like i said if you've ever heard
anybody like referring to like the luton
bus talking about a jump scare
that's what they're talking about
because there's a very famous scene in
this where
irina is like walking down the street
and there's like a noise and noise noise
and it sounds like growling
and you think some like an animal is
like sneaking up on her and then like
this bus comes is like
it's like this thing so it's like it's a
one of the very earliest jump scares
and it's kind of like iconic so if you
haven't seen that you should probably
check it out that was from 1942.
number seven i'm gonna go with nosferatu
1922. maybe i should have put that
higher i don't know i feel bad about it
but i really really like nosferatu
and that movie shouldn't have existed
though they tried to wipe that one out
well it almost did get wiped out um
because
i don't know if you guys know but
because it was based on dracula
but um bram stoker's
widow bram stoker was dead by this time
but bram circus widow was like hey [ __ ]
you can't like make a [ __ ] adaptation
of dracula
without my say-so so like well we're
gonna do it anyway we're gonna change
all the names
um so they did that and then she was
just kind of like
yeah no so i'm gonna sue and she did and
it was successful
so basically the court said you have to
destroy
all the copies of this now a lot of the
copies of it were destroyed
but not all of them somebody who still
had one like floating around someone
which thankfully because
this was i mean
this honestly nosferatu
might be the closest adaptation of the
novel
i mean it it's way closer than dracula
from the 1930s
it's way because it actually makes
the vampire look like what he looked
like in the book
he looks like a gross ass like a rat rat
and i like that they made him like
monstrous and stuff because they didn't
really you know
you know the original dracula bellagosi
which i love and which is on this list
you know spoiler alert but um
i feel like that was kind of the start
of making vampires like all
suave and handsome and blah blah but in
the book
he looked like a gross rat like stinky
old man right so i kind of feel like
nosferatu
leaned into that and um
i want to say too like in my 2000s i
think in my 2000s list
another movie you know i'm jumping out a
little bit but another movie
that's on my list i think is shadow of
the vampire
which was a movie that was about the
making of nosferatu
but that it posited that the dude that
played nosferatu mac shrek
was actually a vampire which
if you see him in the movie you can kind
of believe it because he
looked inhuman
yeah he had the big [ __ ] ears and the
[ __ ] i mean just
all the [ __ ] about that like all the
[ __ ] about like the shadow going up the
[ __ ] i mean that's so good
the imagery in that is so good so you
know just gonna say
actually i think
if i remember correctly
the version of um
nosferatu that we have was one of the
surviving versions
i think there were a couple other edits
if i remember correctly
i don't know if there were it's like i
kind of feel like they destroyed
most of the prints um except for one or
two
i know there have been a couple of other
edits and there have been a couple of
other ones that people have added their
own soundtracks to because obviously
it's a silent movie so you can kind of
like put whatever
i mean even in the 80s and 90s i feel
like it's like some goth bands were like
hey here's nosferatu
but with our score to it yeah
i know that the um that old phantom of
the opera
there's like a [ __ ] ton of edits there
was a [ __ ] ton of edits even back then
yeah because it started off as a silent
movie that got converted into a talkie
it was right at about that time and we
evidently only have like a couple of
edits
there's a bunch of other ones that are
long that have been lost
do you know about that i don't know like
well
the thing about the opera and yeah and
the thing about the silent era
is that unfortunately a large proportion
of movies from the silent era
are totally gone they're gone yeah um
because
they made them on one they made them on
silver nitrate stock which
i don't know if you know but is like
super combustible so
a lot of that stuff doesn't keep real
well and if you didn't if it wasn't like
a big movie that anyone wanted to
preserve it would like just like blow up
and burn down
like nobody like thought to keep it so
it's really kind of sad like i said on
my blog i used to do a um
a series called uh scary silence
and there are so many but like i even
talked about one on there it was like a
russian
silent film i think it was called the
portrait and i think it was based on a
story by uh what's his [ __ ] face um
nikolai google and there's only eight
minutes of that film
remaining it's like it used to be as far
as they know
um you know at least an hour and 20
minutes long hour and a half whatever
and so much of it was lost because
they didn't really know about like
preserving films or like they didn't
really care about it so it's like a lot
of silent films from that era have been
completely lost i think badgers making a
comment about um
phantom of the opera
i remember that there's a scene in the
fan of of the opera that we have where
somebody comes out of a damn
cave and they're talking to the camera
but there's no audio and
it's my understanding that the audio
track was lost
or there was never an audio track that
it had something to do with it being a
silent movie at one time
and they had lost the board that had the
the audio right so they didn't know what
he was saying but it's some kind of a
it's somebody establishing the the scene
the movie
there was evidently a lot of stuff
caught cut
out of the original phantom of the opera
that is just like long gone long gone
and it was replaced by newer uh
cuts that were added later because
evidently that movie happened
right as it was transitioning from
silent to talk
to talking sure and there were like
several edits of both silent
and talky and they got mushed together
in different
ways and shown in several different
regions of the united states and most of
the
virgins versions of them are gone all we
have is i think
two different talky versions and they're
evidently both wrong
it's like a bunch of [ __ ] really sad
because i think what happened at the
time like you had in the 20s and 30s
they were putting out a lot of horror
movies and i think they were kind of
like at the time they were just thinking
they were
um you know throw away or like
expendable
it's like these are just like a horror
movie no one's gonna care about these
like [ __ ]
80 years from now so they would just put
them out they didn't really care that
much about preserving them
or doing because they didn't have i mean
i'm not blaming them they didn't have
like
the foresight to see that like you know
maybe 80 90 years from now it's like
people will be like oh this is a classic
and we should have like preserved it
but they don't so they didn't really
give that much of a [ __ ] about it
no they just thought it was kind of like
a throwaway harm during the silence like
teenagers are gonna watch it
during the silent era movies were [ __ ]
anyway
they were something that were kind of
cooked up uh as a scam
to sell to audiences in little theaters
they never intended in keeping these
things
it was just something to yeah it's only
now
that you see that it's like a classic
and it's like it's amazing
now back then there were so many of them
it's like they don't really give a [ __ ]
it's cheap disposable [ __ ] and they
weren't even they weren't really even
taking it serious back then
they just which is sad but they were
just trying to get asses into seats
yeah that's all it was kind of like a
something out of a carnival
yeah they weren't they weren't reputable
um
anything else and horror movies
particularly anything associated with
theater was
wasn't reputable an actor was an an
actress was a synonym for a hooker
back in that day for a long time yeah
yeah yeah it might still be
but uh because that's where the money
actually came from they didn't live off
of
ticket proceeds they lived off of
selling ass basically to expensive um
or high class fans that saw them at the
theater
this goes back to the wild west you know
where you had things called stars
and stars were hookers that sang
at the brothel you went you saw them put
on a show
if she was a star and she actually sang
she cost more money that's really where
all that [ __ ] comes from
it's all it was all things of ill repute
it wasn't until later uh to the silver
screen era
of the of the depression that actors and
actresses became
quote respectable end quote but i don't
think they were according to
the surviving stories about what
the way old hollywood was they were
always bad
yeah if you want to judge them that way
they were always naughty
let's just put it that way they were
always i don't know
yeah we have skeletons they were always
naughty
and uh you know casting couches
selling servicers selling services
uh going to parties uh they were the
[ __ ]
jet set well before there was a jet set
these were the [ __ ] party crowd
and they were a lot like carnies yeah
yeah yeah can i have one of those like
yeah yeah you took them away i didn't
take them away
you didn't i just used them right over
there i can't get these things are good
what flavor are these they're all
different kinds okay almost
all different kinds all right so what
number i'm at okay so
not for our two we talked about that
number six
the mummy 1932. i
love boris karloff everybody knows that
and the makeup in the mummy i know this
is more of a drama than a horror movie i
want to say
but boris karloff's
look as the mummy
i'm just i'm so into it it looked so so
[ __ ] good and i liked that there was
like a whole [ __ ] love story with it
i like the whole like i love ancient
egypt [ __ ] anyway
so i was just kind of like man boris
karloff with the [ __ ] mommy [ __ ] i
love that she just
love that [ __ ] i love that [ __ ] serpent
serpent surfer says the wild west
amounts to hookers and cocaine
well they didn't call doc holliday the
fastest gun in the west
for nothing this is a doc holiday
wherever he went had a huge jar of that
dab cocaine he put it in the middle of
the gambling table
a jar of cocaine they put it yeah big
glass jar cocaine they
all put it in their wine they drink it
those were all
uncontrolled items back then they didn't
have a uh
an fda or anything like that it wasn't
illegal it wasn't illegal and they
didn't really understand any kind of
negative effects but no they drank
cocaine and
wine they drank cocaine and soft drinks
it was all to
sober you back up so you could drink
more uh yeah they also did morphine and
stuff you know they just
it was not what people thought it was
you know like
the old west was really closer to what
you seen in an eastwood movie
and a and a [ __ ] spaghetti western
you know it wasn't like a 1950s you know
[ __ ] gunsmoke episode
pokes the post-apocalyptic [ __ ]
the 1950s were the biggest lie that
anyone was ever told yeah
they wanted to make everything look all
sanitized clean and sanitized and proper
nothing has ever been like that ever so
i don't really know where
no they were some bad teeth
[ __ ] doing a lot of drugs
[ __ ] shooting people
during arguments and they shot people in
the back they were just [ __ ] regular
criminals
really sure in a lawless area
now they also kind of had gun control a
lot of those towns when you showed up
you had to
give your guns up they didn't want you
in the damn saloon with a gun
you know they took they took you know
[ __ ] common sense measures you know
you know they could it took common sense
common sense precautions you didn't want
a bunch of range bombs
walking around with guns in the middle
of the damn town they'd cheat each other
um but yeah hookers booze
drugs trying to make money uh
running cattle running cattle cowboys
mostly stained [ __ ] put
uh they also transported cattle from one
place to another
the dudes you had to watch for were
[ __ ] gunfighters
who lived in towns tried to make money
tried to get street cred by shooting
guys
they were big into the hookers and their
girlfriends were hookers and
gambling you know and then you just had
bandits people that robbed you while you
were going from one town to the next
you know and also it wasn't
wasn't as white as they [ __ ] try to
make it look
especially way out west lots of mexican
bonjitos
and uh they have black guys out there
too uh i once saw
i had a really good time life book
series
um when i was a kid by the wa wild west
it was all leather bound
and it showed a photograph of a gang of
dudes that were going to be hung for a
[ __ ] murder spree
robbery across three different states
and it was
when you saw who these bad asses were it
was like
seven or eight kids teenagers
some white ones some black ones and some
mexican ones and that's
that was what was really going on and
they looked they were like 16
17 they were [ __ ] kids and
that's who they're making those damn
that's really who they're making those
[ __ ] wild west movies about
if you saw them today you're just like
that's them
yeah that's them it was [ __ ] wild
it was wild they were young and dumb and
they just came from everywhere
so what's the next one brian green says
wax work is another silent classic i
know i had to take that one off because
i had too many
but that was on my list too just fyi
so we're at number five dracula 1931.
i mean bella lugosi
you guys um obviously based on the stage
play
not necessarily on the novel it was kind
of like
but it's iconic it's so iconic
that people still do when you say you
know dracula or vampire people still do
that [ __ ] accent
like bella the ghost he had um
so and he got buried in his dracula cape
sadly he ended up with like [ __ ]
edward which you know i love ed wood
but bella the gossip i kind of feel like
dessert better
you know um so yeah i'm going with that
it's it's a good flick
based on the stage play not on the novel
so don't get all like head up about that
number four i'm gonna go with
frankenstein
right also from 1931. because like i
said
i'm a huge boris karloff fan so anything
he's in
is awesome also number three i'm going
to go with
uh freaks 32 what
let's show him the gang of those dudes i
was telling you about telling them
oh [ __ ] every time i turn one of these
[ __ ] around
the photo disappears that's what they
look like
trying to get that [ __ ] to focus
they sent us them all to death
trying to see what the name of that gang
was
it was the rufus buck gang that's what
they were
roof is booked go ahead jen all right so
like i said number three is freaks
directed by todd browning now this was a
um an infamous film
this was a movie that when it came out
um
i guess because he used real circus
freaks
in the movie and a lot of people kind of
couldn't handle that so there was like a
lot of stories about
back in 1932 like people going to see
the movie in the theater and they were
like throwing up in the aisles or
running out of the [ __ ] [ __ ] being
like oh my god i can't [ __ ] take it
you know what i mean
so basically the story is
i mean it's like the little person of
the
um you know circus and he's kind of like
getting it on with the [ __ ]
um whatever her name is like the [ __ ]
uh she a tightrope walker or something
like that she's like an acrobat
and they kind of get together to like
kill her husband who i think is a strong
man
and um it doesn't really go so well
and then at the end cleopatra
which is her name and she gets turned
into essentially the geek
that thing and a lot of people because
these were
real quote unquote circus freaks
were really really uncomfortable with
this
portrayal but
the thing about it though is that the
circus freaks characters are very um
sympathetic so i don't really know i
mean they're the good guys
the normal looking people are the bad
guys so i i never really found all that
problematic
but it's like it's an infamous movie you
like i said if you're in a horror movies
you really need to see freaks
from 1932. it's really really good
um so my number two and like i said this
is 1900 to 1960 so i'm just like
compressing several decades into this
[ __ ] number two bride of frankenstein
because i will admit
bride of frankenstein is a better movie
than frankenstein frankenstein is a good
movie i'm not saying that
no bride of frankenstein was better
bride of frankenstein was a better movie
than also elsa manchester come on
with the hair i love it it's like that's
[ __ ] iconic
and plus they added a lot too well
the thing was is that when she came out
she wasn't around long enough
sure that was the only thing because i
remember when she came out and she was
ready i
wanted to see like another hour of her
in that outfit
you know what i mean and i love that
she's just like
she looked like that and she just like
she's not having it and she didn't want
well you brought me back to life it's
like what you want me to like what yeah
she didn't want the monster she wanted
the [ __ ]
she wanted dr frankenstein [ __ ] what's
that that means
i mean you know the monster was kind of
cobbled together
from corpse park she was a lot better
mate
so he hit that like yeah he made some
[ __ ]
yeah and the thing about bride of
frankenstein it's like honestly like all
the [ __ ] about the bride and everything
that was
in the original novel frankenstein but
what happened in the original novel was
that
franken or the monster frankenstein's
monster
was kind of like hey make me a mate
because i'm
lonely i'm the only one that's like been
cobbled together from corp card so what
the [ __ ]
and so he does that
but then this is so funny to me
but then he thinks to himself like he
has her all like put together and
whatnot
in the book and then he's like oh well
um maybe i shouldn't animate her because
if the two of them [ __ ] they'll have
like all these weird like mutant babies
and they'll like take over the earth
which is dumb because i mean
okay i'm not going to get on mary
shelley's case because back in the old
days it's like
okay if you could bring a person like if
you could stitch a person back together
from corpses
and could bring them to life right
it would be very easy to just like hey
i'm making a woman she won't have a
uterus
right like that nowadays that would be
like really obvious but back then i
guess it wasn't super obvious
so that's kind of like what and then the
doctor is just like oh no i can't do
this i can't like
proliferate these like monsters all over
the earth so he's like have to destroy
her
and that was the main thing that made
the monster mad and made him wanna like
he's like
[ __ ] i'm gonna kill everybody so that's
kind of like what happened with that
but it's just like it seemed like it
would have been a really simple solution
for me to make the bride
and make her not have a uterus so she
couldn't like reproduce
and honestly if you okay realistically
if you sewed people together from
corpses and then
reanimated them which okay fair enough
i'll give you that
but if you could do that and they
tried to like make it like would that
even work i don't know
but like i said i'm not gonna [ __ ] on
mary shelley because
it was written a long time ago and they
didn't like know what we know nowadays
so it's kind of unfair to like [ __ ]
cast that [ __ ] backwards but you know
what i'm saying
but yeah i've generally i'm saying bride
of frankenstein
i love the original frankenstein but i
think bride of frankenstein is a better
movie
um also it has like some aspects of
horror comedy
which i was kind of into that like i
liked the whole aesthetic of it i just i
don't know i just i i really liked
brighter frankenstein and that's
probably so that's my number two
and um number one i don't know where tom
went but whatever number one
is my is a cabinet of dr caligari
from 1920. now i
love german expressionism i just love
the look of it i just love that they're
like look we're going to take people's
mental states
and we're going to like put it into like
the set dressing it's like
oh no oh no oh no
no oh no
oh no god [ __ ] damn it
god damn it
everybody's still there or no did it
crash
did it crash it might have it's still
moving
no this is still moving this is not
moving
see what your [ __ ] says you're saying oh
it's freezing oh god damn it no no i
just came back we're on there we're on
we're on are we yeah they're still
working i can't see they're still
harassed they still said yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah nope oh
go ahead and full screen that my laptop
crashed though your laptop
no it doesn't no didn't is it it's
running over here
maybe crashing i don't know we'll see
yeah my [ __ ] crashed well it crashed ah
no no no it's still running it's running
man don't [ __ ] do this to me man
i'm gonna get really annoyed i'm gonna
get i'm drunk enough
yeah but i can't i can't see my though i
can't see it in my comments i can't see
anything look my [ __ ] keeps stopping all
right guys we're gonna we're gonna
[ __ ]
open up a new stream okay yeah because
i don't have the patience for this one
yeah we're not opening a new stream
okay yeah it's gone it's gone uh an
aspect
okay starting a new stream
christ's sake wait wait wait oh wait
wait wait